A LOT OF MEMBERS ARE STILL
PRESENTING BILLS AND DIFFERENT
COMMITTEES MYSELF WILL HAVE TO
JUMP FROM HERE TO- GEO
COMMITTEE- BUT WE'RE GOING TO
GET IT STARTED AND THEN- MY
COLLEAGUE- ASSEMBLY. WOMAN WENDY
CARILLO WILL TAKE OVER THE
MEDIUM TO FULFILL THAT THE PANEL
PANEL WANTED THEN HOPEFULLY
WE'RE BACK BY PANEL TO. TO BUSY
DAY IN THE LEGISLATURE BUT- WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
HAVING HEARINGS ON. MISSING AND
MURDERED AND INDIGENOUS- PERSONS
INDIGENOUS WOMEN FROM THE NATIVE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY AND MAKING
SURE THAT ADVOCACY CONTINUES TO.
MOVE FORWARD THIS MORNING WE HAD
A PRESS CONFERENCE THAT WAS
COMMEMORATING NATIONAL MISSING
AND MURDERED INDIGENOUS PEOPLE'S
DAY. AND TOMORROW ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE A RESOLUTION. THAT WILL DO
THE SAME THING AND MOVED TO
DOESN'T IT MAY AS THE MISSING
AND MURDERED INDIGENOUS PERSONS
MONTH- IN TWENTY TWENTY THE
NATIONAL INFORMATION PRIME
CENTER REPORTED ALMOST. FIVE
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED CASES OF
MISSING INDIGENOUS WOMEN. BUT
THE NUMBERS ARE PROBABLY MUCH
HIGHER BECAUSE NOT ALL CRIMES
ARE REPORTED. BECAUSE VICTIMS
ARE MISCLASSIFIED UNDER OTHER
ETHNICITIES- PARTICULARLY IN IN
URBAN AREAS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ON SOME RESERVATIONS
HOMICIDE RATES ARE MORE THAN TEN
TIMES THE NATIONAL AVERAGE- A
NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF JUSTICE
FUNDED- STUDY. FOUND THAT MORE
THAN FOUR. OUT OF FIVE AMERICAN
INDIAN AND ALASKA NATIVE WOMEN
HAVE EXPERIENCED VIOLENCE IN
THEIR LIFETIME. THESE NUMBERS
INCLUDE THE ALMOST 49% WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCE STOCKING. AS YOU WILL
LEARN- TODAY THROUGH THE
TESTIMONY THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR FROM THE DIFFERENT PANELS
THAT ARE THERE. THAT WE'RE GOING
TO HEAR DIRECTLY FROM THOSE THAT
ARE ON THE FRONT LINES IN IN-
INDIAN COUNTRY AS FAR AS HOW WE
COULD MOVE FORWARD TO BETTER THE
RELATIONSHIP AND TO ENSURE. THAT
THE VOICES OF THOSE- THAT. GO
THROUGH THESE TYPES OF AREAS OUR
LOVED ONES THAT WE KNOW THAT
WE'RE ABLE TO WORK TOGETHER TO
ADDRESS THESE THINGS AS A STATE
LEGISLATURE. AND FORMING
PARTNERSHIPS- ALONG THE WAY.
THESE ARE AREAS THAT WE WANT TO
DRASTICALLY DEAL WITHIN MY
COLLEAGUES- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARDIO. WE WORK TOGETHER ON
MENTAL HEALTH AND TRAUMA THERE'S
ANOTHER BILL THAT WERE BOTH ON-
THE S. WORD DEROGATORY NAME
TOWARDS NATIVE AMERICAN WOMEN
THAT'S MOVED OUT OF COMMITTEE.
AND THAT'S MOVING FORWARD BUT WE
KNOW THAT THAT'S THE MENTALITY
THAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA-
ORIGINALLY HAS AND MANY STILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE THAT PERCEPTION
OF NATIVE AMERICAN WOMEN- IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SO WE'RE
WORKING HARD TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE ADDRESSING. THOSE ISSUES.
THAT ARE THERE. AND WE CONTINUE
TO WORK TOGETHER- IN
PARTNERSHIPS AND- THIS END UP-
THIS HEARING AND THE PRESS
CONFERENCE IN THE PLAY TONIGHT
AT FIVE O'CLOCK. AT THE
AUDITORIUM IS ALL IN
CONJUNCTION- WITH THE ASSEMBLY-
WOMEN'S CAUCUS. WHO AT THE LAST
MEETING THAT WE HAD LAST HEARING
THAT WE HAD ON THIS TOPIC. IT
WAS BROUGHT OUT THAT WE NEED TO
BROADEN THE ADVOCACY NOT SO MUCH
JUST KEEP A BOTTLE IN- INDIAN
COUNTRY NATIVE AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES. BUT ALSO GAIN
ALLIES ALONG THE WAY AND I'M
HAPPY TO REPORT THAT WE HAVE
WITH THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS. AT THIS
TIME I'D LIKE TO- TURN IT OVER
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER IDEAL TO
OFFER A FEW WORDS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND- WELCOME TO
EVERYONE HERE IN OUR MEETING
ROOM AT CALIFORNIA STATE CAPITAL
I'M GLAD THAT WE'RE HERE STEVE
AND HEALTHY AMID THE PAST TWO
YEARS COVERT NINETEEN. THIS IS
ONE OF THE FIRST- OPENING SELECT
COMMITTEES THAT ARE HAVING- A
HEARING AT THE STATE CAPITOL
WHICH I THINK IS. ONE IT HAS
BEEN HISTORIC TO BEGIN THE
HERINGS TO ESTABLISH THE NATIVE
AMERICAN CAUCUS. AND TO REALLY
BRING FORWARD VOICES- THAT HAVE
BEEN MARGINALIZED AND UNDER
REPRESENTED ACROSS OUR STATE
REALLY AN ISSUE THAT HAS BEEN.
BUT NOT AS WIDELY SPOKEN ABOUT
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND THAT. IS
THE TOPIC OF AND THE CRISIS OF.
IF THE DEAL WITH THE SUBJECT AND
TO ENSURE THAT WE MOVE FORWARD
AN AGENDA THAT IS INCLUSIVE. TO
ALL PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU ALL FOR. THANK YOU- THANK
YOU SENATE MEMBER CARDIO. A GOOD
FRIEND AND END UP ALIVE TO THE
INDIAN PEOPLE IN THE STATE F
CALIFORNIA. TODAY THE PANELS
THAT WILL HAVE WE A PANEL ONE
THAT WILL UPDATE ON
IMPLEMENTATION OF AB THIRTY
NINETY NINE- AND THE CURRENT
CALIFORNIA DATA SNAPSHOT. IN
THOSE PRISONERS WILL BE MERRY
LOPEZ KEY FOR WHO'S THE DIRECTOR
OF NATIVE AMERICAN AFFAIRS. OF
THE OFFICE OF ATTORNEY GENERAL
ROB BONTA WE ALSO HAVE DR- LIFE
AND GEORGE. AND WILLIAM HANS
WILL HELP HUMBOLDT COUNTY
SHERIFF AND BOARD MEMBER- RIVERS
IN THE STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION. THERE WILL HAVE
PANEL TO THE CALIFORNIA ADVOCACY
EFFORTS AND INITIATIVES WE'LL
HAVE APRIL MCGILL DURING THEIR
OF COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS AND
PROJECTS- CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM
FOR URBAN INDIAN HEALTH. WILL
HAVE JANET BUILT CHAIRWOMAN KUN
RANCHERIA OF THE CHASSIS
INDIANS. AND REGINA CLARK
CHAIRWOMAN SHINGLE SPRINGS BAND
OF MIWOK INDIANS. DONALD THREE
WILL BE- PREVENTION
INTERVENTION- AND POLICY IDEAS-
CHAIRMAN JOE JAMES OF THE YUROK
TRIBAL COUNCIL. AND CHAIRWOMAN-
ERICA PINTO FROM THE HALL MOVE
INDIAN VILLAGE OF CALIFORNIA AND
SERRA DUSKY CHAIRWOMAN OF THE I.
OWN BAND ME WALK INDIANS. THOSE
WILL BE OUR PRESENTERS FOR THE
DIFFERENT PANELS THAT WE HAVE
TODAY AT THIS TIME WE LIKE TO
CALL A PANEL ONE TO COME TO
THIS- TABLE UP FRONT. AND HOW
MANY PRISONERS THREE RIGHT.
SO WE HAVE MARIE LOPEZ KIEFER DR
BLIGHTED GEORGE. AND WILLIAM-HANSON HUMBOLDT COUNTY SHERIFF
AND BOARD MEMBER STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION. WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
OPEN UP THE TESTIMONY WITH MERRY
LOPEZ KIEFER DIRECTOR OF NATIVE
AMERICAN AFFAIRS OFFICE OF
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
GO AHEAD. ACTUALLY. THIS IS YOUR
YOU CAN. ONE ON. ONE
TRY AGAIN. WHEN I CAN TRY AGAIN
HELLO. YES THE MORE TIME HELLO.
GOOD BYE. IS IT BETTER BETTER
YEAH OKAY AWESOME. THEN I WILL
START AGAIN BECAUSE I HAVE A
REALLY NICE LITTLE SCRIPT. ALL
RIGHT. IF BEFORE BEFORE WE BEGIN
LET ME JUST MAKE SURE THAT WE
AND I KNOW OUR CHAIR HAS TO GO
PRESENT A BILL IN COMMITTEE AND
WILL RETURN SO JUST FOR THE
PURPOSE OF- IDENTIFICATION TO
THOSE THAT ARE WATCHING- ONLINE
AND FOR HISTORICAL PURPOSES DOES
REALLY QUICKLY ON BIOS MERRY
LOPEZ A KEY FOR DIRECTOR OF
NATIVE AMERICAN AFFAIRS OFFICE
OF ATTORNEY GENERAL BONTA WILL
GIVE A RECAP OF WHAT HAS
OCCURRED SINCE THE PASSAGE OF AB
THIRTY NINETY NINE AND THE FIVE
MILLION. BUDGET ALLOCATION THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I'M A SECURE
LAST YEAR TO PROVIDE BADLY
NEEDED RESOURCES FOR THIS WORK
TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
MS LOAFERS- LOPEZ KIEFER WILL
FOLLOW WILL BE FOLLOWED BY DR
BLACK GEORGE WHO WILL PRESENT
DATA ABOUT WHAT THE DATA IS
SHOWING US SHE IS A MEMBER OF
THE EUROPE TRIBE AND HAS WORKED
TO DOCUMENT TO ISSUE HUMBOLDT
COUNTY SHERIFF WILLIAM HAN SO
WE'LL DISCUSS LOCAL EFFORTS AND
COLLABORATION WITH OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT ENTITIES AND THE
TRIBES THAT. THE TRIBES AND WHAT
SUPPORT IS NEEDED FROM THE STATE
AB PLEASE BEGIN THANK YOU. THE
MUSEUM. HELLO EVERYONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MARY LOPEZ
KEEPER. HI I AM A MEMBER OF THE
SAN LUIS REY BAND OF MISSION
INDIANS TRADITIONALLY AND
CULTURALLY AFFILIATED. WITH
NORTHERN SAN DIEGO COUNTY. I
SPEAK TO YOU TODAY. AS YOU
RENOUNCED IN MY CAPACITY AS THE
DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF NATIVE
AMERICAN AFFAIRS. AT THE OFFICE
OF ATTORNEY GENERAL ROB BONTA
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE- THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARILLO. AND THE
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON NATIVE AMERICAN
AFFAIRS. AND THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS-
TODAY I WILL SHARE WITH YOU AN
UPDATE ON THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY NINETY
NINE. AND A FIRM GENERAL BONTA
IS COMMITMENT TO WORKING IN
COLLABORATION AND COORDINATION
WITH OUR LOCAL. STATE TRIBAL
FEDERAL JUSTICE PARTNERS. AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY WITH THE
SURVIVORS AND FAMILIES IMPACTED
BY LOVEDONES WHO HAVE GONE
MISSING IN AND ARE HAVE BEEN
VICTIMS OF HOMICIDE. LAST AUGUST
BOTH COMMITTEES HEARD FROM
MYSELF AND OTHERS ABOUT THE
NATIONAL MISSING MURDERED
INDIGENOUS PEOPLES CRISIS AND
CALIFORNIA'S RESPONSE WITH THE
ENACTMENT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY NINETY NINE. SO WHAT I'LL
BE SHARING TODAY IS FIRST I'LL
BE PROVIDING A SNAPSHOT- A
CALIFORNIA'S NATIVE AMERICAN
POPULATION AND THEN A BRIEF
SUMMARY OF AB THIRTY NINETY
NINES MANDATE TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE AND OUR CURRENT
EFFORTS IN IMPLEMENTING THE LAW
. SO JUST TO GIVE PERSPECTIVE-
THE POPULATION. AND NUMBERS FOR
CALIFORNIA AND ITS NATIVE
AMERICAN CITIZENS AT CALIFORNIA
IS HOME TO ONE OF THE LARGEST
POPULATIONS OF AMERICAN INDIAN
ALASKAN NATIVE PEOPLE. ACCORDING
TO THE TWENTY TWENTY U. S.
CENSUS BUREAU. THERE ARE AN
ESTIMATED ONE MILLION FOUR
HUNDRED AND NINE THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED AND NINE AMERICAN INDIAN
ALASKAN NATIVES IN CALIFORNIA.
WHO SELF IDENTIFIES SUCH
ACCOUNTING FOR APPROXIMATELY
THREE POINT 6% OF THE STATE'S
POPULATION. THE TOP FIVE
COUNTIES WITH THE MOST AMERICAN
INDIAN ALASKAN NATIVES PERSONS
ARE LOS ANGELES SAN DIEGO
RIVERSIDE SAN BERNARDINO AND
ORANGE COUNTIES. THE TOP FIVE
COUNTIES WITH THE GREATEST
PROPORTION OF AMERICAN INDIAN
ALASKAN NATIVE PERSONS ARE
ALPINE WITH 22% THAT MEANS ONE
IN FIVE PEOPLE IDENTIFIED AS
AMERICAN INDIAN ALASKAN NATIVE.
INYO COUNTY AT 17% DELL NORT AT
14% HUMBOLDT AT 11% AND SISKIYOU
COUNTY AT 10% THE GENDER DISPUTE
DISTRIBUTION OF AMERICAN INDIAN
ALASKAN NATIVE POPULATION IN
CALIFORNIA ACCORDING THE TWENTY
NINETEEN CENSUS. IS
APPROXIMATELY EQUAL WITH BOTH
MEN AND WOMEN ACCOUNTING FOR
AROUND 50% OF THE POPULATION.
AND IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE HOME TO
APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY ONE CALIFORNIA NAY
NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES
CONSISTING OF ONE HUNDRED AND
NINE FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES
AND APPROXIMATELY SIXTY TWO NON
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES AND
A LITTLE OVER ONE HUNDRED INDIAN
RESERVATIONS AND RANCHERIAS THAT
NEIGHBOR THIRTY FOUR OF OUR
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY JURISDICTIONS
. NOW I WILL SUMMARIZE AB AB
THIRTY NINETY NINE KEEPING IN
MIND THOSE POPULATIONS. I AM
SIGNED INTO LAW SEPTEMBER TWENTY
FIFTH TWENTY TWENTY ON
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN DAY-
THE LOT ADDRESS TOO LONG OVERDUE
CONCERNS EXPRESSED BY
CALIFORNIA'S NATIVE AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES. THE FIRST WAS THE
NEED TO HAVE STATEWIDE
CONSISTENCY IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF PUBLIC LIFE
EIGHTY THREE TO EIGHTY ALSO
KNOWN AS P. L. TWO EIGHTY AT THE
TRANSFER CRIMINAL JURISDICTION.
ON INDIAN LANDS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO THE STATE. THE
SECOND WAS TO ADDRESS THE
GROWING CRISIS A MISSING AND
MURDERED NATIVE AMERICAN
PEOPLE'S PARTICULAR LEE WOMEN
AND GIRLS AND CALIFORNIA'S
INDIAN COUNTRY. AND BROADER
NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITIES. AS
DISCUSSED LAST SUMMER TO ADDRESS
ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS AB THIRTY
NINETY NINE CREATED THE TRIBAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE'S OFFICE
OF NATIVE AMERICAN AFFAIRS AND
MANDATED THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WITH THREE SPECIFIC
TASKS. CASK WINE IS TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE REGARDING
POLICING AND CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATIONS ON INDIAN LANDS
CONSISTENT WITH PUBLIC LOCK TWO
EIGHTY. TAX TO WAS TO CONDUCT A
STUDY TO DETERMINE HOW TO
INCREASE STATE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
PROTECTIVE AND INVESTIGATIVE
RESOURCES FOR REPORTING AND
IDENTIFYING MISSING NATIVE
AMERICANS IN CALIFORNIA. AND HAS
THREE IS TO SUBMIT A REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE BASED ON THE
FINDINGS OF THE STUDY DESCRIBED
IN PAST TWO. BY THE END OF
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE. THIS REPORT WILL
INCLUDE RECOMMENDATIONS AND
PROPOSED LEGISLATION TO IMPROVE
THE REPORTING AND IDENTIFICATION
OF MISSING NATIVE AMERICANS. AN
EXAMINATION OF DATA REGARDING
CURRENT MISSING AND MURDERED
NATIVE AMERICAN PERSONS IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE
IDENTIFICATIN OF POTENTIAL
BARRIERS TO PROVIDE STATE
RESOURCES NEEDED TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES. AS SHARED BY
GENERAL BONTA WE ARE CURRENTLY
IN YEAR ONE OF FIVE OF OUR
IMPLEMENTATION OF AB THIRTY
NINETY NINE. AS FAR AS WHAT
WE'RE DOING RIGHT NOW BECAUSE WE
DID RECEIVE THE FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN OCTOBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- AND WE HAVE HIT THE
GROUND RUNNING- WE ARE CURRENTLY
BUILDING A MULTI DISCIPLINED
TEAM. TO ACHIEVE OPTIMUM SUCCESS
IN IMPLEMENTING AB THIRTY NINETY
NINE. INCLUDING CONTRACTING WITH
NOTED NATIVE AMERICAN RESEARCHER
AND ASSISTANT PROFESSOR AT UC
MERCED DOCTOR BLACK GEORGE. TO
LEAD OUR RESEARCH TEAM AND CAST
TWO AND THREE WE'RE VERY EXCITED
- WE HAVE ALSO ENGAGED WITH MANY
CALIFORNIA TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS
TRIBAL COURTS AND TRIBAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND NATIVE
LEAD VICTIM ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATIONS REGARDING AB
THIRTY NINETY NINE. AS WELL AS
BUILDING I'M A NEW PARTNERSHIPS
WITH OUR LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND THROUGH THEIR TRIBAL
LIAISONS. WE CONTINUE TO
COLLABORATE AND COORDINATE WITH
OUR LOCAL STATE TRIBAL FEDERAL
JUSTICE PARTNERS CONDUCTED
TRAININGS ON THE ENFORCEMENT OF
TRIBAL COURT PROTECTION ORDERS
AND HAVE ISSUED INITIAL GUIDANCE
TO LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES REGARDING PEEL TO
EIGHTY FOR THE IMPROVE SAFETY ON
INDIAN LANDS. WE ARE CURRENTLY
DEVELOPING IN COLLABORATION WITH
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS AND NATIVE
AMERICAN MISSING PERSONS
FREQUENTLY ASKED QUESTION OUR
FAQ. THAT WILL SHOW THE HOUSE
WHAT'S WHEN'S AND WISE ON WHAT
TO DO IF A LOVED ONE OR A TRIBAL
MEMBER GOES MISSING. WE KEEP
APPRISED OF NEW DEVELOPMENTS IN
COMBATING THE IMPACTS BROUGHT
UPON BY THE CRISIS OF MISSING
MURDERED NATIVE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND CONTINUOUSLY UPDATE THE
OFFICE OF NATIVE AMERICAN
AFFAIRS WEBSITE. TO PROVIDE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY WITH
VITAL INFORMATION. IN CLOSING
AND I SHARE BY GENERAL BONTA
EARLIER TODAY. WE ARE IN THE
EARLY PHASES OF IMPLEMENTING AB
THIRTY NINETY NINE. AND WE ARE
BUILDING A MULTI DISCIPLINED
TEAM TO ENSURE MEANINGFUL
RESULTS FOR THE TRIBAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. WE ARE
ACTIVELY ENGAGING WITH TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS LOCAL STATE TRIBAL
JUSTICE PARTNERS AND NATIVE LED
ORGANIZATIONS AND ASSESSING AND
ADDRESSING THE ISSUES RAISED IN
AB THIRTY NINETY NINE. THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
REMAINS COMMITTED TO THE SAFETY
AND WELL BEING OF TRIBAL PEOPLE
AND THEIR COMMUNITIES WE ARE
COMMITTED TO DOING OUR PART TO
STAND UP FOR ALL OF THE PEOPLE
IN OUR STATE. THANK YOU. KNOW
SOME OF IT. THANK YOU SO MUCH-
THE DIRECTOR LOPEZ KEY FOR WE
WILL NOW GO ON TO OUR DOCTOR
PLACE GEORGE. PLEASE PROCEED. I
AGREE NEXT NOW DOCTOR BY STORAGE
MCKINLEY ROCK HELLO MY NAME IS
DR BY GEORGE I'M ORIGINALLY FROM
MECHNICAL CALIFORNIA LOCATED IN
HUMBOLDT COUNTY ALONG THE LOST
COAST OF FAR NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. I'M CURRENTLY AN
ASSISTANT PROFESSOR OF SOCIOLOGY
AT UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
MERCED TO MY KNOWLEDGE I'M THE
FIRST YOU'RE A PROFESSOR TO
TEACH IN THE UC SYSTEM. I'M A
MEMBER OF THE IRAQI TRIBE AND
THE RESEARCH PARTNER FOR THE
TACKY SCHOOL ISAAH NAY WATCH
CHECK I WILL SEE YOU AGAIN IN A
GOOD WAY PROJECT A PROJECT WHICH
DOCUMENTS THE SCOPE AND SEVERITY
OF MISSING AND MURDERED
INDIGENOUS WOMEN. GIRLS AND TWO
SPIRIT PEOPLES IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA KNOWN AS MMIWG TWO
WITH AN EMPHASIS ON INTERVENING
IN THE CYCLES OF VIOLENCE BY
DESIGNING AND IMPLEMENTING BEST
PRACTICES AND PROTOCOLS FOR
TRIBES LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
JUSTICE SYSTEM AGENCIES IN
ADDRESSING MMIWG TO CRISIS. THIS
PROJECT IS FUNDED BY THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE'S
COORDINATED TRIBAL ASSISTANCE
SOLICITATION ALSO KNOWN AS A C.
TASK GRAHAM AND THE BUREAU OF
INDIAN AFFAIRS TRAVEL JUST TO
SUPPORT. I'VE BEEN ASKED HERE
TODAY TO SPEAK ON THIS PROJECT
FROM THE LEVEL OF THE DATA THE
RESEARCH ON THE GROUND AND WHAT
WE KNOW THAT'S FAR. NO MATTER
WHAT I SAY HERE I WANT TO
PREFACE IT WITH GRATITUDE TO THE
SURVIVORS VICTIMS AND FAMILIES
WHO LIVE THIS DAY EVERY DAY IT
IS ONLY BECAUSE OF THEIR
VULNERABILITY AND THEIR
WILLINGNESS TO LET US LEARN FROM
THEIR DEEP PAIN LOSS AND GRIEF.
THAT I CAN SPEAK ON THIS ISSUE
IN ANY SUBSTANTIVE WAY AND THEY
MAKE THESE LESSONS KNOWN TO US
SO THAT WE MAY IN SOME WAY HELP
THEM SEEK CLOSURE FIND JUSTICE
AND ULTIMATELY HEAL FROM THE
MANY WAYS IN WHICH MMIWG TWO AT
HIGHLANDS AGAINST INDIGENOUS
WOMEN MORE BROADLY. IMPACTS OUR
COMMUNITIES EVERY AS INDIGENOUS
PEOPLES. I HAVE A PHD IN
SOCIOLOGY AND SOCIAL POLICY FROM
HARVARD UNIVERSITY BY MANY
ACCOUNTS I WENT TO THE BEST
SOCIOLOGY PROGRAM IN THE COUNTRY
AT THE BEST SCHOOL IN THE WORLD.
I SET UP THESE CREDENTIALS SO
THAT WHEN HAVE A CHANCE TO SPEAK
IN ROOM SAFE IS THIS HE WOULD
LISTEN. NOT BECAUSE THE WORDSI
WOULD SAY WOULD CHANGE OR THE
PEOPLE I SPOKE FOR WOULD BE
DIFFERENT BUT RATHER BECAUSE
WITH SUCH A- YOU WOULD KNOW THAT
I SPEAK FROM A PLACE OF GREAT
EXPERTISE. GET AS MUCH AS I HAVE
THIS EMPIRICAL SKILL SET FIRST
AND FOREMOST I AM A EUROPE
WOMEN. IN EARNER OR FROM THE
COAST AND INDIGENOUS WOMEN WHOSE
FAMILY HAS ALWAYS LIVED. IN WHAT
IS NOW SET LEARNING HUMBOLDT
COUNTY. MY BLOODLINE HAS LIVED
IN THE VILLAGES OF REC WALK.
WELL KERR AND PICK ONE SINCE
TIME IMMEMORIAL. I STAND BEFORE
YOU BECAUSE I'M IN A POSITION TO
SPEAK ON THIS CRISIS FROM BOTH
THE PROFESSIONAL AND PERSONAL
LEVEL. I SEE WITH THE EYES OF A
SOCIAL SCIENTIST A SOCIOLOGIST
WHO SPECIALIZES IN PRISONER
REENTRY INEQUALITY AND MMI P.
VERSED IN A VARIETY OF EMPIRICAL
METHODS. BUT FIRST AND FOREMOST
I IDENTIFY AS A STORYTELLER. A
STORYTELLER WHO IN NO WAY MAKES
ANY CLAIMS TO OBJECTIVITY NOR
WANTS TO. HOW COULD I BE
OBJECTIVE WHEN I A YUROK WOMAN
FROM THE LOST COAST. HAVE BEEN
TASKED WITH COUNTING TRACKING
AND EXPLAINING THE SCOPE AND
SEVERITY OF OUR MISSING AND
MURDERED RELATIVES IN THE STATE.
TRUTH BE TOLD WHEN I LOOK AT THE
DATA I SEE MYSELF. I DON'T SEE
MYSELF BECAUSE THEY SHARE SO
MUCH IN COMMON WITH MANY OF THE
ENTRIES. I SEE MYSELF IN THE
DATA BECAUSE IN THE LAST YEAR
ALONE. I KNEW THREE OF THE WOMEN
WHO WERE TAKEN FROM US. FOR THE
SAKE OF THEIR PRIVACY AND THAT
OF THEIR FAMILIES. I SPEAK ONLY
GENERALLY ON THEIR CASES. FOR
THE FIRST WOMAN IT WAS HALFWAY
THROUGH THE PANDEMIC WHEN I READ
HER NAME. AS BRIGHT OF A WOMAN
WHO ONCE PLAYED WITH ME UNDER
THE BLEACHERS AT THE INTER
TRIBAL ELDERS GATHERING. AND
THEN WE CHIU TOGETHER FOR YOUTH
FOOTBALL. SHE WAS FOUND FAR FROM
HOME. LIFTED INSIDE A SUITCASE
AND FOUND BY A STRANGER. THE
NEXT WOMAN THROWN CARELESSLY TO
THE SIDE BY GOD KNOWS WHO
MEMBER. WHO AFTER ENJOYING HER
COMPANY HEARING HER LAUGH SEEING
HER EYES THAT WERE SO PRETTY.
THEY MADE HONEY JEALOUS. THEY
LEFT HER FOR DEAD AT THE BOTTOM
OF A HILL TOP. SHE TOO WOULD BE
FOUND BY A STRANGER WHO HAD MORE
COMPASSION THAN THE PERSON. WHO
LEFT HER THERE. THEN LAST
OCTOBER MY FRIEND WAS TAKEN FROM
US. NO ONE KNOWS HOW OR WHY. ALL
WE KNOW IS IT SHE VANISHED IN
THE MOST REMOTE CORNER OF OUR
RESERVATION. AND A PLACE I WOULD
ARGUE IS ONE OF THE MOST REMOTE
REGIONS IN THE LOWER FORTY EIGHT
STATES. NOW IT IS SOMEONE I LOVE
SOMEONE I HAD TO SPACES ON THE
MISSING PERSONS FLYER. AND NOW
I'VE BEEN CALLED HERE TODAY TO
SPEAK TO YOU FROM THE LEVEL OF
THE DATA. BUT AS I SAID I'M A
STORYTELLER AND I HAVE TO LET
YOU KNOW THAT BEFORE I CAN SPEAK
ON ANY OF THESE TRENDS. I HAVE
TO BRING THESE STORIES TO BEAR.
I ONCE THOUGHT I HAD READ EVERY
BOOK EVERY STUDY KNEW EVERYTHING
THERE WAS TO KNOW ABOUT THIS
ISSUE. BUT THERE WERE LESSONS I
HAD NOT YET LEARNED AND WITH
THESE THREE CASES. TEACHINGS I
NEVER WANTED BUT NOW WALK WITH
NONETHELESS HAVE COME TO ME. AS
AN INDIGENOUS WOMAN I KNOW THAT
I AM MORE LIKELY TO EXPERIENCE
VIOLENCE AND SERIOUS HARM THE
NOT. A RISK THAT FOLLOWS ME
ACROSS THE LIFE COURSE. THE ONLY
OTHERS TO SHARE THIS BURDEN ON
MY FELLOW INDIGENOUS RELATIVES
OF ALL GENDERS. WE ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY LIKELY TO
EXPERIENCE VIOLENCE AND DEATH
ACROSS THE LIFE COURSE. WHEN
COMPARED TO ALMOST EVERY GROUP.
YET EVEN STILL WHEN SPEAKING ON
THIS EPIDEMIC WE MUST FRIENDS
STAGE THE UNIQUE EXPERIENCE OF
WOMEN. GIRLS INTO SPIRITS
BECAUSE IT IS THESE GROUPS. THAT
HAVE HAD THE DISTINCTION OF
EXISTING SQUARELY WITHIN. THE
CROSSHAIRS OF THE SETTLER
COLONIAL PROJECT. THEY WERE
TARGETED. SHE'S ME THEIR
CAPACITY AS LIFE GIVERS. AND
SPIRITUAL KNOWLEDGE KEEPERS. FOR
THE VERY REASONS FOR WHICH THEY
WERE TARGETED FROM THE FIRST
DAYS OF THE INVASION. AND THEY
ARE THE REASONS WHY NOW IN
PRESENT DAY WHEN THEY ARE
HARMED. THEY'RE JUST GO
UNNOTICED UNSOLVED OR WORSE.
MUCH WORK REMAINS ON HIS TOPIC
THAT BASED ON OUR WORK WITH I
WILL SEE YOU AGAIN IN A GOOD WAY
WE KNOW SEVERAL THINGS TO BE
TRUE. WE KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA'S
IN THE TOP FIVE FOR MMI W. P.
CASES. WITH EIGHTEEN CASES IN
THE LAST YEAR ALONE IN THE
STATE. OVER HALF OF THESE CASES
WERE LOCATED NORTH OF THE BEAR.
AREAS THOSE CASES OF. FOR WITHIN
THE- OF THE HUMBOLDT COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT. THIS MEANS
THAT JUST ONE RURAL POLICE
DEPARTMENT IS RESPONSIBLE FOR A
SIGNIFICANT SHARE OF MMI W. P.
CASES IN THE STATE. YET LIKE
OTHER RURAL POLICE FORCES. THERE
GENERALLY UNDERFUNDED STRUGGLE
TO MAINTAIN STAFFING. AND I'M
GOING TO DATE AND THE ONGOING
DAILY LAW ENFORCEMENT CALLS.
LEAVE LITTLE ROOM FOR THE VITAL
WORK OF COLD CASE CLOSURE. NO
MATTER HOW IMPORTANT THESE CASES
ARE TO THE SHERIFF AND MANY
OTHERS AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AND JUSTICE SYSTEMS
THE VERY REAL CONSTRAINTS PLACED
ON THEM BY RURAL POLICING.
LIMITS OUR ABILITY TO
EFFECTIVELY RESPOND TO THE
CRISIS. NO MATTER THEIR
COMMITMENT OR EFFORTS TO SOLVE
CASES. RURAL POLICE AND THEIR
TRAVEL COUNTERPARTS. LACKS THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO
ADEQUATELY ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
AND THIS IS HANDS DOWN THE
BIGGEST RECOMMENDATION.
THANKFULLY PARTNER WITH THE
TRIBAL NATIONS. THAT SHARE THEIR
JURISDICTION. BY OFFERING THE
MUCH NEEDED RESOURCES TO DO SO.
CHIEFLY PUBLIC LAW TO EIGHTY
SHOULD BE ADDRESSED AS IT LEFT
TRIBES WITHOUT THE RESOURCES. TO
FULLY STAFF TRAVEL ON FORSMAN.
AND WE MUST BETTER SUPPORT THESE
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES. AS
THEY ARE CLOSEST TO THIS CRISIS
. AT PRESENT WE ALSO KNOW THAT
THESE NUMBERS ON MISSING AND
MURDERED ARE CONTEXTUALIZED
WITHIN GRIEVOUS VIOLENCE AGAINST
INDIGENOUS WOMEN AND INDIGENOUS
BODIES WERE GENERALLY.
INDIGENOUS WOMEN ARE AT A HIGHER
RISK OF INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE TRAFFICKING. AND MORE
LIKELY TO EXPERIENCE SERIOUS
VIOLENCE KIDNAPPING AND HOMICIDE
THAN THEIR NON INDIGENOUS
COUNTERPARTS. HOMICIDE IS THE
THIRD LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH FOR
AMERICAN INDIAN AND ALASKA
NATIVE WOMEN WITH THE VIOLENCE
EXPERIENCED BY INDIGENOUS WOMEN
BEING ESPECIALLY SEVERE AND
FREQUENTLY A PRECURSOR TO THEIR
DISAPPEARANCE OR DEATH. GOING
FURTHER NATIVE WOMEN ARE
MURDERED MORE LIKELY TO
EXPERIENCE INTERRACIAL VIOLENCE
WHICH IS FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT
THAN INTRA RACIAL VIOLENCE. MORE
OFTEN THAN NOT WHEN INDIVIDUALS
ARE VICTIMIZED IS TYPICALLY BY
SOMEONE OF THEIR SAME RACE. THIS
IS NOT THE CASE FOR INDIGENOUS
WOMEN ARE PERPETRATORS ARE MORE
LIKELY TO BE NON NATIVE. AND
AGAIN THAT'S LINKING BACK TO THE
SETTLER COLONIAL LEGACY WHERE
OUR BODIES ARE THE LANDSCAPE BY
WHICH COLONIAL VIOLENCE HAS BEEN
AND CONTINUES TO BE WAGED. OUR
FOUNDING MYTHS ARE BUTTRESSED BY
DISGUSTING TRUTH IF YOU HARMON
INDIGENOUS WOMEN YOU ARE MORE
LIKELY TO GET AWAY WITH IT. WE
ENSCONCED THIS IN LINE EVEN
RESERVATIONS IS CASE IN POINT
ARE AREAS RIFE WITH
JURISDICTIONAL LOOPHOLES LEGAL
COMPLEXITIES AND ULTIMATELY
CRIMINAL SILENCE. ROVING SERIAL
KILLERS OF WHICH THE FBI
ESTIMATES ARE OVER FIFTEEN
HUNDRED CIRCULATING IN OUR
NATION AT THIS VERY MOMENT. AND
ALL THOSE OTHERS WHO WOULD DO
HARM TO WOMEN SEEK OUT THESE
PLACES AND THE BODIES OF WOMEN
LIKE ME WHO LIVE THERE BECAUSE
THEY KNOW THEY WILL NOT GET
CAUGHT. AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE
NUMBERS IT'S HARD TO DISPUTE
THIS INTERPRETATION MURDERS OF
NATIVE WOMEN IN THE STATE ARE
SEVEN TIMES LESS LIKELY TO BE
SOLVED IN SIMILAR CASES WITH NON
NATIVE VICTIMS. EVEN WITH SUCH
TRENDS WE KNOW THE STATE IS ONLY
A FIRST GLANCE. AND AS A PROJECT
WE ARE LEFT SIFTING THROUGH WHAT
DATA DO EXIST TO BETTER SPEAK TO
THIS CRISIS. EVEN AS SO MANY
FAMILIES AND SURVIVORS KNOW IT
WELL BEYOND THE CAPACITY FOR ANY
METRIC TO FULLY CAPTURE. DRAWN
FROM THE DATA AND THE LESSON
SHARED WITH THIS BIG HE
STAKEHOLDERS WE OVERWHELMINGLY
UNDERSCORE THE NEED TO DO THE
HARD WORK OF ESTABLISHING THE
PRACTICES AND PROTOCOLS. THAT
ARE UNIQUE TO THIS MATTER IN
PARTICULAR BUT ALSO RELEVANT TO
CALL CASES AT LARGE. ACCORDING
TO THE FEDERAL DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE IS SPECIAL JOURNAL
ISSUES ON M. M. I. W. P. WE ARE
IN A CRISIS OF COLD CASES IN
THIS COUNTRY AND THIS
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTS.
INDIGENOUS WOMEN AS WE MAKE UP A
SIGNIFICANT PROPORTION OF THESE
OPEN CASES. ULTIMATELY WE NEED
TO INVEST THE RESOURCES INTO
ESTABLISHING A VARIETY OF
MECHANISMS. FROM BEFORE SOMEONE
IS TAKEN AFTER THEY'RE MISSING
OR MURDERED. OR AND THROUGH CASE
CLOSURE. IN OUR YEAR TO REPORT
DUE FOR RELEASE IN JULY WE WILL
TAKE A FIRST STEP IN DESIGNING
SUCH PROTOCOLS. AS PART OF A
TRIBAL COMMUNITY RESPONSE PLAN
OR T. C. R. P. AS RECOMMENDED BY
THE EDERAL GOVERNMENT. FOR
DRESSING THE MMI W. P. CRISIS
WILL MAKE THESE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO THE STATE AND ALL
OTHER TRIBES. AS A BE READY FOR
USE IN REAL TIME BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND JUSTICE SYSTEM
AGENCIES. SERVICE PROVIDERS AND
ALL OTHER STAKEHOLDERS. SOMEONE
RECENTLY ASKED ME WHAT DOES IT
MATTER THAT THE YUROK TRIBE IS
MOVING ON THIS ISSUE. WHAT CAN
ONE LITTLE TRIBE DUE. TO WHICH I
REPLIED THERE IS NO LITTLE TRIBE
IN A STATE LIKE OURS. CALIFORNIA
IS BY SOME ACCOUNTS THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD NOT
JUST THE NATION. WHEN WE TAKE
THIS ISSUE SERIOUSLY AND WE MAKE
INTERVENTIONS THAT ARE NEEDED.
THIS WILL HAVE IMPLICATIONS FOR
THE WHOLE OF INDIAN COUNTRY AND
PERHAPS GLOBAL INDIGENOUS
COMMUNITIES AT LARGE. IT IS
VITAL THAT WE TAKE ACTION AND
THAT EACH OF YOU STAND ON THE
SIDE OF BEING ABLE TO DO THAT.
BECAUSE PEOPLE WILL LISTEN WHEN
CALIFORNIA MOVES ON THIS ISSUE.
AND THAT COULD BE A TEMPLATE FOR
SO MUCH. REMEMBER THAT YOU'RE
NOT ALONE IN THIS EITHER TRIBES
ARE HERE TO COLLABORATE. IF YOU
IN YOUR RESPECTIVE DISTRICTS
HAVING ALREADY REACHED OUT TO
THE LOCAL TRIBES. DON'T WAIT FOR
THEM TO CALL YOU. CALL THEM
TODAY AND MAKE TIME TO SIT WITH
THEIR COUNCIL. THERE'S SO MUCH
THAT WE IS TRIBES COULD BRING TO
THE TABLE. THERE ARE
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM. ARE UNIQUELY SUITED TO
DO IS THOSE WHO KEEP US SAFE.
BUT THERE'S ALSO TASK TO WHICH
WE IS TRIBES ARE UNIQUELY SUITED
TO DO. THAT COULD HELP THEM IN
THESE EFFORTS. AND THESE
TEACHINGS ARE JUST FOR US.
THERE'S POWERFUL MEDICINE HERE
THAT COULD BE SHARED WITH SO
MANY COMMUNITIES IN SIMILAR
CONDITIONS. WE NEED TO ACT NOW.
IN CLOSING I MUST REMIND YOU
THAT NO DATA ANYWHERE CAN FULLY
CAPTURE WHAT IS LOST WHEN OUR
RELATIVES ARE TAKEN. OUR NUMBERS
NO MATTER HOW DIRE. CAN ONLY
FALL SHORT OF SHOWING HOW MUCH
IS LOST WITH EACH INDIGENOUS
LIFE. FAR TOO OFTEN AS SOCIAL
SCIENTISTS WE TALK ABOUT DATA
ESPECIALLY HARD NUMBERS. AS SOME
KIND OF GOLD STANDARD. I KNOW
FIRST HAND HOW THIS CAN NEVER BE
THE CASE NOR THE AND ALL. WHEN
IT COMES TO THIS EPIDEMIC. EVEN
AS WE FASHION STUDY INSTRUMENTS
TO CAPTURE THIS CRISIS. EVEN THE
BEST TOOL FAILED TO CAPTURE THE
RIPPLING ABSENCE. THAT CASCADES
THROUGH THE LIVES OF THOSE LEFT
BEHIND. CHILDREN LOSING MOTHERS
FAMILIES LOSING SISTERS COUSINS
SIBLINGS. AUNTIES LITTLE SISTERS
AND BABY COUSINS. LEAVING AND
NEVER COMING HOME AGAIN. THEIR
VOICES NO LONGER SING OUR SONGS.
THEIR HANDS NO LONGER RADAR
HERE. THEY'RE NOT THERE TO TAKE
CARE OF THEIR PARENTS. OR THEIR
CHILDREN. WHO SIT INSTEAD IN THE
ABSENCE OF THEIR LOVED ONE.
WALKOUT FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
YOUR ATTENTION AND YOUR ACTION.
THANK YOU. A DOCTOR GEORGE AND I
THINK OF. MY CALLING FROM THE
SAN GABRIEL VALLEY AND I JUST.
WOULD LIKE TO JUST ACKNOWLEDGE
AND SHARE IN YOUR GRIEF. AND
THANK YOU FOR SHARING AND I'M SO
SORRY. AT FOR THE THREE WOMEN
THAT YOU KNEW PERSONALLY. AND TO
EVERYONE HERE- IN TERMS OF WHAT
THIS TRULY MEANS- FOR WOMEN AND
FOR GIRLS. YES PLEASE GO AHEAD
YES THANK YOU FOR THAT- I. I
KNOW THAT YOUR PAIN IS AND IN NO
COMPARISON BUT I- I WAS BORN IN
WHAT IS MEXICO AND YOU KNOW THAT
THERE'S A STORY ABOUT THE WHAT
THE MISSING WOMEN AND WHAT IS ON
FORTUNATELY FROM ME- MY PARENTS
BROUGHT US TO THE TO CALIFORNIA
WHEN WE WERE YOUNG SO WE DON'T
GET TO EXPERIENCE THAT BUT I
KNOW. THAT WE HAVE SIMILAR
STORIES AND QUITE AS MEXICO THAT
YOU DO HERE'S ALL AGAIN MY
CONDOLENCES ON. THAT AND- WE
HEAR ABOUT IT BUT- WE HEAR ABOUT
IT. SOMEWHERE SOMETIME IT
HAPPENS SOMEWHERE AND YOU KNOW
IT TO BRING IT HERE AND- MAKE
THOSE VOICES ARE THOSE FACES
REAL AND KIND OF THE STATISTICS
REAL- YOU KNOW IS REALLY
IMPORTANT SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR THE CHANCE TO DO SO
THANK YOU I WAS EXACTLY THINKING
ABOUT THE WOMEN IN WHAT IS IN
YOUR EXPERIENCE AS WELL. AND
AGAIN THANK YOU AND- OUR DEEPEST
CONDOLENCES ON BEHALF OF. THIS
SELECT COMMITTEE THE NATIVE
AMERICAN CAUCUS AND OUR STATE
LEGISLATURE AND THIS IS WHY.
THESE CONVERSATIONS ARE SO
CRITICAL AND WHY THIS HEARING IS
SO INVALUABLE. WE'RE GONNA MOVE
FORWARD- WITH HUMBLE COUNTY
SHERIFF WILL. THANK YOU
SEPTEMBER CARILLO SO MEMBER
RUBIO. SEE THE OPTION TO SPEAK
WITH YOU ALL HERE AND BE A
PARTNER HERE ON THIS PANEL-
DOCTOR BLIGHT- MY LOVE IS KEEPER
WE WORK TOGETHER ALL OF US ON
THIS ISSUE AND HAD OPEN LINES OF
COMMUNICATION OVER LAST COUPLE
YEARS ABOUT THIS AND THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT I'M- HAPPY IS ON THE
FOREFRONT. AND WE SEE NOW BOTH
STATEWIDE AND NATIONALLY THAT
PEOPLE ARE TAKING NOTE BUT IT'S
JUST ONE THING TAKING NOTE. IT'S
ON THE THING TO TAKE ACTION. AND
SO RIGHT NOW IS OUR ACTION
PHASE. AND NOW WERE WE NEED TO
DO SOMETHING. AND NOW WE CALLED
ATTENTION TO THIS. AND NOW WE'VE
COMMUNICATED IT NOW WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER ON THIS ISSUE AND SO
I'M PROUD TO SAY THAT WE ARE.
THERE STEPS THAT WE'RE TAKING-
ON THE STATE SHERIFFS LEVEL AS
WELL AS LOCALLY- TO ADDRESS THIS
AND I APOLOGIZE IT INTRODUCE
MYSELF MY NAME IS BILLY HANS ON
THE SHERIFF OF HUMBOLDT COUNTY-
AND ALSO THE- CHAIR. OF TRIBAL
AFFAIRS FOR THE STATE CHURCH
ORGANIZATION. AND AND I'M HAPPY
TO SAY THAT AS FAR AS A STATE
SHERIFFS GO WE ARE ALL POISED TO
MOVE TOGETHER MOVE FORWARD. WITH
WORKING TOGETHER AND- AND SO WE
SEE THIS AS A STATEWIDE PROBLEM.
HOW WONDER THINGS ARE WORKING ON
A COUPLE COUNTY IS OUR ABILITY
TO WORK TOGETHER WITH THE TRIBES
WORK TOGETHER WITH TRIBAL
POLICE. WE HAVE THREE- DEPUTIES
ATION AGREEMENTS WITH TRIBAL
POLICE OFFICERS. POLICE
DEPARTMENT EXCUSE ME THE YUROK
TRIBE HOOPA TRIBE AND BLUE LAKE
RANCHERIA IT IS SOMETHING THAT I
THINK IS ON THE FOREFRONT OF.
MAKING SURE THAT THAT THE
COMMUNITY NO ONE HAS THE ABILITY
TO POLICE THEIR OWN TO GET OUT
IN IN INTO THE RURAL AREAS OF
OUR COUNTY AND TO HAVE. THE
ABILITY TO ENFORCE STATE LAW AS
YOU KNOW PULIC LOT TO EIGHTY
PUTS THE RESPONSIBILITY ON
ENFORCING THE STATE LAW ON THE
SHERIFF'S OF EACH COUNTY. AND IT
IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO DO SO
BUT WHAT WE CAN DO WHAT WE DOING
HERE IN HUMBLE COUNTY IS MAKING
RESERVE DEPUTY SHERIFFS OF
TRIBAL OFFICERS. WE'RE HOPING
WORKING WITH TRIBAL POLICE
WORKING WITH THE TRIBAL POLICE
SHE'S ASSOCIATION WITH THE OTHER
TRIBES TO TRY AND CHANGE THE
LAW. I BELIEVE IT WOULD BE VERY
BENEFICIAL I THINK THE TIME IS
NOW. TO CHANGE THE LAW TO ALLOW
TRAVEL OFFICERS TO BECOME POST
CERTIFIED IN A FOR STATE LAW ON
TRIBAL LAND. I'VE SAID IT BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE LAST YEAR- I'VE
TALKED TO SEVERAL PEOPLE ABOUT
IT AND WE ARE THERE TO SUPPORT
THAT AND SUPPORT THAT IF IT DOES
COME TO A- THE ASSEMBLY FOR AND
THE LAWS CHANGED- IN THE
MEANTIME. COMMUNICATION
COLLABORATION- WE'VE HAD A
RECENT CASE THAT DOCTOR GEORGE
REFERRED TO AS A MISSING PERSON
BACK IN IN THE FALL AND IT'S A
VERY. HEART WRENCHING STORY.
AND- AND SO. WE WANT TO DO OUR
BEST. IN THESE SITUATIONS AND
THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF THE YUROK
TRIBE HOOPA TRIBE IN HUMBLE
COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE COMING
TOGETHER. AND WORKING TOGETHER
TO TRY AND SOLVE A MISSING
PERSONS CASE- UNFORTUNATELY WE
DON'T HAVE RESOLUTION OF THAT
CASE BUT DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE
ARE. DOING EVERYTHING POSSIBLE
TO TRY AND FIND HER RIGHT NOW-
AND THAT'S INCLUDING BRING IN
OUTSIDE RESOURCES- TALKING THE
BUREAU OF INDIAN AFFAIRS. THE
FBI- EVERY KIND OF RESOURCE WE
POSSIBLY CAN BRING IN TO SOLVE
THIS. AND THAT'S WHAT IT'S GONNA
TAKE BECAUSE IT'S ONE THING TO
DO SOMETHING BUT IT'S ALSO
BUILDING TRUST WITHIN THE
COMMUNITIES. ONE THING WE
RECOGNIZE IS THAT THE
GENERATIONAL DISTRUST WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT PUBLIC LAW TO EIGHTY
WAS FORCED ON THE TRIBES THIS
WASN'T ASKED FOR. THIS WASN'T
COLLABORATED WITH IT WAS FORCED
ON THE TRIBES OF THE STATE- AND
SO WHAT WE CAN DO NOW IS WORK
WITH THE TRIBES ARE TRYING TO
BUILD TRUST. AND THAT HAPPENS
ONE CASE AT A TIME IT DOESN'T
MEAN THAT WE'RE GONNA DO THINGS
CORRECTLY EVERY TIME IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE BUT THERE IS
MECHANISM IS NOW. THAT NGUYEN
MISTAKES FROM WHEN THINGS NEED
TO BE ADDRESSED THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY ADDRESS THOSE WITH EACH
OTHER HAVING REGULAR CHECK INS
WITH THE TRIBAL CHAIR GERMANS
WITH REGULAR CHECK INS WITH THE
TRIBAL POLICE CHIEFS WITH THE
COMMUNITY. AND THAT'S WHAT'S
IMPORTANT AND THAT'S WHAT'S
NECESSARY THROUGHOUT THE STATE
IS HAVING THE SHERIFF'S OR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES THAT IN
CHARGE OF THAT JURISDICTION TO
HAVE. COMMUNITY MEETINGS TO
LISTEN. TO THE PEOPLE. TO LISTEN
TO WHAT'S GOING ON THE GROUND
BECAUSE WHAT I HEAR. ON MY END
COULD BE COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
THAN WHAT THE COMMUNITY
UNDERSTANDS AND HEARS. AND SO
THAT'S ONE THING THAT WE'RE
COMMITTED TO AND THAT'S ONE
THING THAT WE ARE WE ARE WANTING
TO DO- SO. GO AHEAD I'M SORRY TO
INTERRUPT BUT THIS WHOLE ENTIRE
TIME WHEN YOU'RE HAVING YOUR
TELL ME THAT I I'M TRYING TO
THINK BACK DID I MISS ANYTHING
ON THE NEWS BECAUSE IF ANY THERE
WAS ANY OTHER MISSING PERSON IT
WOULD BE ALL OVER THE NEWS- I
KNOW I'M FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BUT I KNOW WE'VE YOU
KNOW THERE'S BEEN SEVERAL
OCCASIONS WHERE THERE'S A
MISSING PERSON AND IT'S ALL OVER
THE NEWS I HAVEN'T SEEN IT IS IT
ME THAT I HAVEN'T SEEN IT OR IS
IT THAT IT'S NOT AS PUBLICIZED.
AS OTHER CASES RIGHT AND YOU
KNOW I **** SAY ASKED SAME
QUESTION OF OUR MEDIA LOCALLY
THAT THE INFORMATION IS PUT OUT
THERE WHAT THEY WHAT CERTAIN
MEDIA OUTLETS TAKE UP AN
ADVERTISE VERSUS OTHERS- WHAT
DRIVES THE NEWS WHAT DR SOCIAL
MEDIA IT IS BEYOND ME IT REALLY
IS- THE FACT IS THAT YOU KNOW US
LOCALLY WE HAVE TO START THERE
AND WE HAVE TO PUSH INFORMATION
OUT WE HAVE TO LET PEOPLE KNOW
AND WE HAVE TO KEEP THIS IN THE
FOREFRONT. AND TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THAT WE ARE
STILL LOOKING- THE ONE THING
THAT WAS ON THE- THE SECOND
REPORTED IN THE MY W. WAS MAKING
SURE THAT EACH JURISDICTION HAS
THE HAS COLD CASES ADVERTISED SO
WE CAN KEEP THE INFORMATION ON
THE FOREFRONT SO THE COMMUNITY
KNOWS THE FAMILY MEMBERS KNOW
THAT WE ARE STILL LOOKING AND
THAT THEIR MISSING AND MURDERED.
LOVE ONE. IT IS STILL A PART OF
OUR CASES AND WE'RE ASKING FOR
HELP. OR ASKING FOR TECHNICAL%
ASSISTANCE OR ASKING FOR
WITNESSES TO COME FORWARD.
BECAUSE WE'VE WE KNOW PEOPLE
NOTICE THINGS. AT TIMES AND THEY
JUST REFUSED TO COME FORWARD AND
I THINK PART OF THAT IS BUILDING
TRUST. WITHIN COMMUNITIES SO
THEY NOW WE DID HAVE. A MISSING
PERSONS CASE IN WHO BOUGHT. LAST
YEAR- WHERE GEMMA WENT MISSING.
AND HIS CAR WAS FOUND. AND AFTER
THE INFORMATION WAS PUT OUT
THERE. COMMITTEE MEMBER STARTED
COMING FORWARD. AND THROUGH
COMMUNITY MEMBERS BEEN ABLE TO
TELL US WHAT THEY KNEW WE WERE
ABLE TO ROUTE IT BACK TO WHERE
THE VICTIM WAS LOCATED. DECEASED
AS WELL AS ARREST THE PEOPLE
THAT MURDERED HIM. AND SO THAT'S
ONE CASE. BUT THAT'S ONE THING
CASE THAT BUILDS TRUST WITHIN
THE COMMUNITY WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO CARRY THAT FORWARD
AND TRY TO DO MORE. BUT AGAIN
IT'S GONNA TAKE ONE CASE AT A
TIME. AND AND SO I'M HERE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS I'M HERE TO
COLLABORATE AND- AND DO WHATEVER
WE CAN BUT I REALLY APPRECIATE
DR GEORGE- AND THE REPORT THAT
THEY THAT THEY PUSH OUT EVERY-
EVERY COUPLE MONTHS. IT IS
IMPORTANT WE DO KEEP THIS IN THE
FOREFRONT. FOLLOW UP QUESTION
TO- ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOUR POINT
IS RIGHT ON CUE IN TERMS OF HOW
THE MEDIA PORTRAYS CERTAIN
STORIES WHEN IT COMES TO
INDIGENOUS WOMEN OR WOMEN OF
COLOR AND GENERALLY WHEN. GONE
MISSING OR A CERTAIN KIND OF
CASES NOT AS ELEVATED AS IT IS A
WITH OTHER INDIVIDUALS AND- WE
KNOW WHAT WE KNOW WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE- MY QUESTION IS THE
COLLABORATION BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF- THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL. AS WELL AS LAW
ENFORCEMENT AS TO WHAT YOU SEE
OUR POTENTIAL OPPORTUNITIES IN
TERMS OF HOW- YOU KNOW EVERY
TRIBE A RESERVATION AS ITS OWN
SOVEREIGN NATION. SO THEN HOW
CAN WE COLLABORATE AS A STATE IN
IMPACTFUL LEGISLATION THAT
SUPPORTS JUSTICE AND SAFETY.
WELL NOT IMPOSING ON TRIBAL
SOVEREIGNTY AND WHAT THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY LOOK LIKE. THAT'S A
GREAT QUESTION- BECAUSE WE DON'T
AND WE DO NOT WANT TO STEP ON
TOES. AND WE WANT TO WORK
TOGETHER AND I THINK THAT COMES
FROM HIS PLACE OF RESPECT I
THINK HAVING EACH TRIBE EVALUATE
THEIR OWN NEEDS AND FIGURE OUT
WHAT THEY- NEED BECAUSE EACH
TRIBAL- ENTITY HAS. THE ABILITY
TO SELF GOVERNED SELF POLICE-
AND EACH EACH- EACH TRIBE. HAS
IN A DIFFERENT STAGE OF THAT YOU
WITH ANYONE EVEN WITHIN OUR OWN
COUNTY WE HAVE DIFFERENT STAGES
OF TRIBAL POLICE. AND SO WHAT
THE YUROK. NEEDS BABY IS
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT BLUE LAKE
NEEDS AND SO I THINK HAVING A
CHECK IN WITH THEM AND- WITH DOJ
WITH MYSELF WITH THE FBI. AND
COMMUNICATE EXACTLY WHAT THEY
NEED IS PROBABLY THAT THE RIGHT
THING TO DO. IT WOULD NEED TO BE
LED BY THE TRIBES- AND AS I
MENTIONED- THERE'S OVER A
HUNDRED RESERVATIONS- AND
THERE'S- THE RESERVATIONS ARE
BORDERED BY THIRTY FOUR OF OUR
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES SO THIRTY
FOUR SHERIFF'S- AND THAT
COORDINATION. AND RELATIONSHIP
BUILDING- BECAUSE THERE ARE
HISTORICAL TENSIONS- JUSTIFIED-
A LOT OF DISTRESSED ISSUES- BUT-
AS- EVERY TRIBE- HAS. INHERENT
SOVEREIGNTY- AND THEY HAVE
CONCURRENT CRIMINAL JURISDICTION
SO THE TRIBES CAN- THEY CAN
IMPOSE OUR OWN CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEMS. WE DON'T HAVE ANY RIGHT
NOW- BUT AS SURE CONSULATES ST
IT'S GOING TO TAKE- A LOT OF. AS
PART IN NATION- AND SHARING OF
INFORMATION BECAUSE RIGHT NOW-
THERE'S NOT ANY REAL SHARING OF
INFORMATION BETWEEN LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THE TRIBES- AND
SO WE NEED TO BUILD BACK KIND OF
PIPELINE- FIRST SO I'M HOPING-
THAT. DR GEORGE OF SHE GETS THE
START WORKING- ON OUR STUDY COME
JULY. WE HAVE TO WAIT FOR YUROK
. I THINK IF I COULD AND I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT RIGHT THE TRIBES
ARE SEEN AS A COLLABORATOR IN A
RESOURCE IN THIS MATTER
TRUTHFULLY THERE'S SOME THINGS
THAT ONLY WE WILL BE ABLE TO DO.
AND I THINK. YOU KNOW I'M CLOSE
TO THIS ISSUE AND THERE'S PEOPLE
EVEN CLOSER STILL WHO ARE ON OUR
PROJECT TEAM LOOKING FOR THEIR
RELATIVES AND- AND THAT IS
ACTUALLY THE STATE OF THIS ISSUE
I WOULD HAZARD A GUESS FOR MOST
TRIBES IT WILL TRY TO. LOOK INTO
THIS ISSUE AND ANY OR EXIT
REPRESENT THEIR INTERESTS WE ARE
OFTEN ONLY ONE OR TWO PEOPLE
REMOVED. AND I THINK THAT OFTEN
THEIR TRIBES ARE AT A LOSS OF
WHERE TO START. AND END YEARS
ONE AND TWO AND IN YEAR THREE WE
ACTUALLY SHARE STUDY INSTRUMENTS
OF THE TRIBES THEMSELVES CAN
START COLLECTING THIS DATA GET
THE SCOPE AND SEVERITY OF WHAT
IT LOOKS LIKE IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. SO THAT WHEN THEY
GO TO WORK WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND JUSTICE SYSTEM THEY HAVE
SOME SOMETHING TO GO ON AND
AREN'T STARTING FROM SCRATCH I
THINK SO. AS MUCH AS WE ASK
TRIBES TO LEAD THE WAY WE HAVE
TO REALIZE THAT THEY'RE DOING SO
WITHIN A VASTLY UNDER RESOURCE
CONTACTS AND SO MAKING RESOURCES
AVAILABLE FOR THIS ISSUE IN
PARTICULAR WOULD ALLOW THEM TO
START ESTABLISHING THOSE BASS
LINES WHICH IN TURN CAN INFORM
OUR INTERVENTIONS. ACT DATA IS
MY WHOLE JAM BUT I DO THINK IT
STARTS WITH BEING ABLE TO
COLLECT THE DATA AND HONORING
TRIBAL ACCESS TO THIS IMPORTANT
DATA ON OUR MEMBERSHIP. A LOT OF
ITS EDUCATION AS WELL AND
PROVIDING THOSE RESOURCES. SO
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE- IS
COMMITTEDTO WORKING WITH THE
TRIBES- PROVIDING THE TOOL KITS
FOR THE DNA COLLECTION. SO THAT
IF THEY HAVE HAD A MISSING LEVEL
AND OUR TRAVEL MEMBER- AND- THEY
HAVE A BEEN GONE FOR AWHILE-
THEY'VE BEEN MISSING AND- WE CAN
GO AHEAD AND HELP COLLECT THAT
DNA. US SO THAT WE COULD PUT IT
IN OUR CODE ASSYSTEM AND IF
THEIR FAMILY MEMBER. IS DECEASED
AND WE CAN BE ABLE TO BRING THEM
HOME FOR THEM. SO THOSE ARE THE
TYPE OF RESOURCES THAT
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE IS LOOKING AT
AND LIKE I MENTIONED THE FAQ I'D
BE ABLE TOPROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION BECAUSE JUST NOT
BEING PROVIDED TO THE TRIBAL
CITIZENS. ANOTHER THING THAT-
IT'S HARD TO TRACK AS FAR AS-
WE'RE TAKING MISSING PERSONS
CASES WE TRACK NATIVE AMERICAN
WE CHECKED THAT BOX WE DON'T
TRACK INDIVIDUAL TRIBES MMHM AND
SO WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
COLLABORATION. THE END AND WE
MAKE REFERRALS ON CHILD ABUSE
CASES TO DIFFERENT DIFFERENT YOU
KNOW TRIBES AS WELL AS WHY CAN'T
WE DO THAT WITH MISSING PERSONS
CASES AND YOU KNOW I TALKED TO
MERRY AND APARTMENT JESS'S LOOK
AT THIS BUT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT IT CAN'T BE AN EASY FIX.
THAT IT'S IT CAN BE A TRIPLICATE
FOR ME CAN BE A FORM THAT'S
EASILY MODIFIED AND ANOTHER BOX
PUT IN THE SYSTEM THAT SAYS THIS
IS THE TRIBE AND THEN ONCE THE
TRIBE IS FLAGGED IN OUR SYSTEM
THAT AUTOMATICALLY GET SENT TO
THAT TRIBE THE TRIBE SIR HAVE.
YOU HAVE NCIC ACCESS AND WE CAN
BE ABLE TO PUT THIS INFORMATION
OUT SO IF THERE'S A YUROK TRIBAL
MEMBER THAT GOES MISSING IN
EUREKA CALIFORNIA AND EUREKA
CALIFORNIA TAKE ARGUE WE GET P.
TAKES A MISSING PERSONS CASES
AND THE FAMILY SAYS THERE ARE
YUROK TRIBAL MEMBER THEY
IDENTIFY THEIR AND THEN THAT
INFORMATION GO THERE SO THEN YOU
OUGHT TRAVEL PLEASE CAN FOLLOW
UP TRIBAL COUNCIL CAN FOLLOW UP
AND THEY CAN OFFER SERVICES TO
THE FAMILY. IT JUST MAKES SENSE
BUT THAT'S ONE THING THAT WE CAN
DO ON A STATE LEVEL TO HELP OUT
WITH THAT COOPERATION AND THAT'S
CONSISTENT WITH THE FEDERAL-
ADVISEMENT ON THIS- IS TO- IF
YOU'RE HAVING THAT REYES
IDENTIFIER- ON ANY OF THE DATA
THAT'S BEEN COLLECTED TO INCLUDE
A TRIBAL AFFILIATION- INDICATOR
AS WELL SO WHEN THE AN
INDIVIDUAL MARKS THE AMERICAN
INDIAN ALASKAN NATIVE BOX OR
NATIVE AMERICAN BOX- TO ALLOW
FOR A POPULAR AUTO POPULATION.
OF THE DIFFERENT TRIBES SO THE.
FIVE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FOUR-
RECOGNIZE TRY IN THE NAY. YOU
CAN HAVE STATE RECOGNISED TRIBES
AS WELL AS- THE NON FAMILY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES IN CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE THAT INFORMATION IT CAN
BE AUTO POPULATED- BUT THIS
WOULD ASSIST. NOT ONLY IN.
HAVING THAT ENGAGEMENT WITH THE
TRIBES SO THAT BACK THAT SHARING
OF INFORMATION IS THERE. BUT
ALSO SHARE COUNCIL MENTIONED
THERE ARE MANY DIFFERENT
SITUATIONS WHERE. I TRIED CAN
BE- HAS RESOURCES THAT THE STATE
DOESN'T HAVE- ESPECIALLY IF IT'S
CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE- FOR
COULD BE FOR CHILD WELFARE
SERVICES IT COULD BE FOR VICTIM
ASSISTANCE IT COULD BE FOR
OFFENDER- AS RE ENTRY. OF
PROGRAMS SO- HAVING THAT
ADDITIONAL IDENTIFIER WOULD BE
VALUABLE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR THIS QUESTIONS I KNOW THAT-
SURE AND ASSEMBLYWOMAN SHARON
QUIRK SILVA HAS ALSO A QUESTION
OR COMMENT- GOOD AFTERNOON AND
PLEASE FORGIVE ME BECAUSE WE
JUST CAME FROM ANOTHER HEARING
SO I DIDN'T GET TO HEAR THE
FIRST INFORMATION. BUT I
UNDERSTAND YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
COLLABORATION AND- CROSS
JURISDICTION- ON AND SO FORTH
AND- ON A PERSONAL NOTE OVER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS AGO BEFORE IT
I WAS AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
TEACHER FOR MANY YEARS AND I
WORKED AS A CHAIR OF A
COLLABORATIVE- THIS IS IN FULLER
TEN SO NOTHING RELATED TO THIS
TOPIC. BUT WE BROUGHT TOGETHER.
MANY AT TO TEASE TOGETHER
EDUCATION PUBLIC SAFETY HEALTH
CARE AND WAS VERY INTENTIONAL TO
MEET MONTHLY TO REALLY DEFINE
WHETHER OR GANG ISSUES WHETHER
IT'S HEALTH CARE EDUCATION
ISSUES. BUT I GUESS WHAT I'M
WONDERING IS DO YOU HAVE A
COLLABORATIVE THAT ACTUALLY
DOES- THAT AND- I KNOW THAT THE
JURISDICTIONS- AS FAR AS- BEING
ABLE TO BE. NEAR EACH OTHER
COULD BE VERY EXPENSIVE BUT
WITH- YOU KNOW REMOTE IT COULD
BE AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE VERY
INTENTIONAL ABOUT WHETHER IT'S
MONTHLY OR QUARTERLY THAT YOU'RE
REALLY GOING TO BRING IN- AS YOU
SAID SOCIAL SERVICES EVEN HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. BECAUSE I KNOW IN
EDUCATION THERE'S ALWAYS BEEN
CAMPAIGNS FOR WHETHER IT'S
LITERACY OR BUT YOU KNOW ALSO
SAFETY SO IF YOU SEE SOMETHING
SAY SOMETHING SO REALLY
EDUCATING NOT ONLY THE FAMILIES
THAT BUT ALSO PEOPLE OUTSIDE OF-
IF OU WANT TO SAY- THE TRIBES
BECAUSE THEY MAY SEE SOMETHING
EVEN IN THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS. OF
DOES THIS- BECAUSE WE'RE ALWAYS
LOOKING IS THIS PERSON LOOK LIKE
THEY'RE UNDER DURESS IS THERE
SOMEBODY THAT MAY NOT WE DON'T
KNOW WHY THEY'RE HERE AND IT
DOESN'T MEAN YOU'RE REPORTING
OUT ON NEIGHBORS FOR NO REASON
BUT I'M JUST SAYING THAT
COLLABORATIVE VERY INTENTIONAL.
AND AN EDUCATION. KIND OF
CAMPAIGN. IF YOU'RE DOING THAT-
ALREADY THAT WOULD BE GREAT IF
YOU ARE JUST DON'T KNOW. I THINK
THAT'S MORE OF A- IT DOESN'T IT
DOESN'T EXIST- IT DEPENDS ON THE
COUNTIES IT DEPENDS ON THE
TRIBES- IT DEPENDS ON THE ISSUE-
TO WHAT BRINGS EVERYONE
TOGETHER- AS FAR AS- MISSING
PERSONS- I WOULD ACTUALLY DIFFER
YOU TO SHARE CONSUL- HUMBLE
COUNTY HAS BEEN- AN EXCELLENT
PARTNER- IT TO THE SURROUNDING
TRIBES- AS FAR AS- AT OTHER
COUNTY SAN DIEGO COUNTY- HAS
BEEN VERY EFFECTIVE- IN THEIR
TRIBAL OUTREACH AND BUILT
REBUILDING RELATIONSHIPS- WITH
THE SAN DIEGO TRIBES- AS WELL AS
RIVERSIDE. COUNTY RIVERSIDE AND
SAN DIEGO COUNTY COMBINED I
REPRESENT A THIRD OF THE TRIBES
IN CALIFORNIA- THEY BOTH HAVE A
LARGE QUANTITY OF TRIBES AND
THEY HAVE BOTH BEEN WORKING
DILIGENTLY IN REBUILDING THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS AND BUT AGAIN IT'S
ON ISSUE SPECIFIC- THAT THAT
DRIVES THOSE COLLABORATIONS- SO
GO AHEAD SHARE CONSUL. SO WHAT
WE DO NUMBER COUNTIES HAVE A
AROUND MEETING AND THE DEEP DISH
ATTORNEY HOST A ROUNDTABLE
MEETING AND ALL LAW ENFORCEMENT
PARTNERS ALL TRIBES REPRESENTED.
AT THE AT THE ROUND TABLE
MEETING AND IT'S A VERY
BENEFICIAL- COLLABORATIVE EFFORT
TO GETTING ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS
TOGETHER DISCUSSPROBLEMS WHILE
THEY'RE STILL SMALL WELL WHILE
THE QUESTIONS ARE STILL SMALL TO
TRY TO ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE
THINGS AND- AND SO IT DOES WORK
WELL- WE DO ME EATS. ON A ONE ON
ONE BASIS WITH TRIBAL POLICE
SHE'S SO SHE XIN DOJ STATE
SHERIFFS- YOU KNOW BUT HAVING A
COLLECTIVE MEETING ALTOGETHER-
IS SOMETHING THAT WE PROBABLY
CAN DO A MAKE THAT ARRANGEMENT
AND TODAY ESPECIALLY IN SOON
AGE. YOU KNOW WE CAN PULL THIS
OFF AND SO IT'S SOMETHING THAT-
ALL ON TALK TO MARY ABOUT AND
MAYBE EVEN REGIONALLY I MEAN AS
YOU SAID IT'S COUNTY BY COUNTY
I'M FROM ORANGE COUNTY AND- YOU
KNOW I'M GOING TO ASSUME BUT I
DON'T KNOW. THAT WE HAVE MAYBE
LESS ISSUES AND SAY RIVERSIDE OR
OTHER AREAS BUT THAT CERTAINLY
DOES NOT MEAN WE DON'T HAVE ANY
ISSUES AND IT COULD ALSO MEAN
THAT WHEN THERE ARE INDIVIDUALS
WHO GO MISSING THEY AND
SOFTWARE. AND IT'S SO IT'S IN
ALL OF OUR BENEFIT TO
UNDERSTAND. THE ISSUE AND TO
MAKE SURE OTHERS DO AS WELL- BUT
I THINK. REMOTE OPPORTUNITIES
REALLY GIVE A WHOLE KIND OF
REGIONAL STATEWIDE OPPORTUNITY
TO- CONVENE AT SOME POINT. IF I
MAY ADD I WOULD SAY THAT I'M THE
TYPE OF RESEARCH FIRST EVE. I
STATE PROJECT WE ACTUALLY
STARTED THE PROJECT ON THE EVE
OF THE PANDEMIC SO HAD IN A VERY
DIFFERENT. AND HAD TO STILL JUMP
IN AND ESTABLISH THE SCOPE AND
SEVERITY AND- FOR TWENTY
NINETEEN LATE TWENTY NINETEEN TO
NOW. WE HAVE SEEN THE
COLLABORATION BETWEEN OUR
PROJECT- THE COUNTY SHERIFF'S
IT'S BOTH WAYS WHEN WE NEED
HELP. WE CAN CALL AND VICE VERSA
AND I THINK THAT THAT'S A REAL
TEMPLATE TO MODEL I DON'T WANT
TO SINGLE ANYONE OUT BUT I WILL
SAY THAT IN THE COURSE OF THE
PROJECT WE INTERACTED WITH A
VARIETY OF COUNTIES. MANY
DIFFERENT LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
THAT WAS NOT ALWAYS THE RESPONSE
THAT WHEN WE CALLED AND ASKED
FOR THEIR TIME THAT WE WERE
SEEN. AS WORTHY OF THAT TIME OR
OR SOMETIMES THE- WE WERE COMING
IN A GOOD WAY I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
WHEN TRIBES COME TO COLLABORATE
ON THIS ISSUE. THEY ARE COMING
TO BRING RESOURCES IN TO HELP
AND HAVING A RECEPTIVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OPEN TO THAT HAS
BEEN INSTRUMENTAL AND I HOPE
THAT WE CAN SHARE FROM THOSE
LESSONS IN OUR YEAR THREE
REPORT. THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY ON ON PANEL ONE-
THANK YOU FOR YOUR- YOUR
COMMENTS HERE FROM THE- THERE
COMMITTEE. AS WE TRANSITION TO
PANEL TO. I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- REGGIE JONES
SAWYER. ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO
GARCIA. ASSEMBLY WOMAN SHARON
QUIRK-SILVA. ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
ROBERT RIVAS FOR- JOINING US
HERE FOR THIS VERY IMPORTANT
TOPIC. AN ASSEMBLY UP BLANCA
RUBIO WHO HAD TO PRESENT A BILL
AND IS ON HER WAY BACK. PANEL
TO- WILL CONSIST OF APRIL MIGUEL
WHO'S DIRECTOR OF COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIPS AND PROJECTS OF
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF URBAN
INDIAN HEALTH WILL START THIS
PANEL AND DISCUSS URBAN ADVOCACY
SINCE SERVICES. AFTER THAT- THE
CHAIRPERSON JANET BILL. OF THE
PICAYUNE RANCHERIA CHASSIS
ENGINES WILL SPEAK THEN AFTER
THAT- THE CHAIRPERSON OF SHINGLE
SPRINGS- BAD TO ME LUCK ENGINES
REGINA CLARK WAS SPEAK AND
THAT'S PANEL TO. SO WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND START THE DISCUSSION
IN THE TESTIMONY- FROM APRIL
MCGILL THEY WILL GO TO CHAIR
PERSON- JANET BILL AND THEN
CHAIRPERSON REGINA CLARK. WELL
YEAH. THANK YOU- AND GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE THANK YOU
SOME OF AN ALMOST FOR BRINGING
US TOGETHER HERE TODAY TO BRING
ATTENTION TO CALIFORNIA'S
EPIDEMIC OF MMI P. THANK YOU
TONY GENERAL BONTA FOR ALL YOUR
SUPPORT TO THE AMERICAN INDIAN
PEOPLE AND- AND- THANK YOU
DIRECTOR OF THE AMERICAN AFFAIRS
MERRY LOPEZ KEY FOR INVITING. ME
TO SPEAK ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
ADVOCACY EFFORTS AND INITIATIVES
. AGAIN MY NAME'S APRIL MIGUEL
MINERAL NUMBER OF ROUND VALLEY
AND I'M A U. Q. DESCENDANT.
TODAY I REPRESENT THE WORK I DO
AS DIRECTOR OF COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIPS AND PROJECTS AT THE
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM FOR URBAN
INDIAN HEALTH LEADING THE RED
WOMAN RISING PROJECT. AND THIS
PROJECT IS TO BRING ATTENTION TO
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND SEXUAL
VIOLENCE MMI P. AND ALSO BRING
ATTENTION TO JUST VIOLENCE.
AGAINST OUR ENVIRONMENT AND- AND
I AND I OFTEN SAY THAT BECAUSE-
WE HAVE TO HONOR THAT CONNECT
CONNECTION BETWEEN THE
ENVIRONMENT AND  VIOLENCE
THAT- HAS BEEN PUT ON OUR
ENVIRONMENT TO THE WATER TO THE
LAND WHICH IS. IMPORTANT TO OUR
TRAVEL RELATIVES- CALIFORNIA IS
HOME TO ONE OF THE LARGEST
HOLOCAUSTS IN HISTORY THAT IS
KNOWN TO CALIFORNIA INDIAN
PEOPLE AS THE GOLD RUSH. OUR
STATE GAVE WHITE SELLERS
PERMISSION TO KIDNAP TRAPPING IN
SLAVE AMERICAN AND WOMEN AND
CHILDREN. AND THAT'S KNOWN AS IN
MY P. BUT PEOPLE STILL REFUSE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND BELIEVE THAT
THIS HISTORY EVER EXISTED IN
CALIFORNIA. MANY OF US HAVE
ANCESTORS WHO ARE PART OF THE
BOARDING SCHOOL AREA HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND STILL CARRY THAT
GENERAL GENERATIONAL TRAUMA.
FROM THE THEIR ANCESTORS
EXPERIENCES A BOARDING SCHOOLS
WHEN- PEOPLE TODAY WONDER WHY-
WE CALIFORNIA ARE ONE OF THE TOP
STATES- OF THE HAVE THE HIGHEST
IN MY P. WE KNOW IT IS BECAUSE
OF THAT DARK HISTORY OF
CALIFORNIA- IN THAT. INDIAN
GENOCIDE AND I HONOR MY
GRANDMOTHER ADELINE FULL WIDER
WHO IS A U. Q. DESCENDANT WHO IS
ALSO. A SURVIVOR OF BOARDING
SCHOOL. SO I AM ONE OF MANY
ADVOCATES HERE IN CALIFORNIA-
IT'S HONOR TO BE HERE AND SAY
THAT I DO THIS WORK THIS WORK IS
VERY PERSONAL- I HAVE LOST
FRIENDS. JESSICA ALBA- WHO WAS
MURDERED IN SAN FRANCISCO IN
TWENTY NINETEEN I ALSO OWN MY
NIECE- NATASHA STEEL BATIDA IN
DELMAR COUNTY. WHICH WAS- SHE
WAS HER DEATH WAS PRONOUNCED A
DROWNING WITH NO INVESTIGATION.
BUT SO PLEASE READ WOMAN RISING
PROJECT- YOU KNOW IS REALLY
FOCUSED ON URBAN INDIAN
POPULATIONS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
SICKLY REPRESENTS TEN OF OUR
URBAN INDIAN HEALTH- PROGRAMS
HERE. AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND THAT- IT EVEN THOUGH
WE LIVE IN URBAN COMMUNITIES WE
ARE STILL TRIBAL PEOPLE WERE
STILL CONNECTED TO- TO OUR
TRIBES AND HAVE FAMILY THAT-
COME INTO URBAN COMMUNITIES FOR
SAFETY FOR PROTECTION. AND FOR
RESOURCES. SO OF THE RED ROOM
AND RISING PROJECT IS REALLY A
WAY TO- UP LIFT VOICES OF OUR
SURVIVORS AND WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO- TO CREATE. A TV NETWORK HERE
IN CALIFORNIA WHICH IS- A
NETWORK THAT MEETS- OF MONTHLY
AND QUARTERLY. AND THAT'S JUST
TO CREATE VISIBILITY WITHIN ALL
OF ORGANIZATIOS TO SHOW WHAT
WORK THEY'RE DOING WITHIN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. WE ALSO- PROVIDE A
LOT OF RESOURCES SUCH AS OUR
READ WOMAN RISING WEBSITE FOR
SURVIVORS WE HAVE OR DIGITAL
STORIES THAT WE'VE WE'VE- TALKED
TO SURVIVORS ABOUT OUR POLICY
ADVOCACY WORK. AND DIRECT
EMERGENCY SERVICES THE COOLEY IS
NOT AN EMERGENCY A SERVICE
ORGANIZATION BUT WE FOUND THAT
ESPECIALLY DURING COPA NINETEEN
WE HAD TO PROVIDE DIRECT SERVICE
IN FUNDING FOR SHELTERS AND
HOTEL ROOMS FOR SURVIVORS. WHO
WERE- WHO NEEDED TO BE HOUSED
FOR PROTECTION. WE ARE STRONG
PARTNER I'M HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE A PARTNERS WITH IN A
TRIBAL COUNCIL CALIFORNIA THE
STRONGER NEED WOMEN'S COALITION
WHO WE REFER A LOT OF OUR-
SURVIVORS TO. AND AND ALSO WITH
THE OF RESTORATIVE JUSTICE FOR.
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO THAT WE OFTEN PARTNER
WITH AS WELL. CURRENTLY WE ARE-
CREATING A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE-
REPORT WHICH IS AN ENVIRONMENTAL
SCAN OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE FOR
CALIFORNIA AMERICAN POPULATIONS
AND THAT IS WITH- THE UNIVERSITY
OF SAN FRANCISCO. AND IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE DO THIS
STATE WAY DATA- REPORT BECAUSE
WE NEED THIS DATA TO FOR POLICY
CHANGE AND UCSF HAS BEGUN TO.
OUTLINED IDENTIFIED GAPS IN
STATE WIDE TV DATA FOR AMERICAN
INDIAN POPULATIONS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA IN THIS REPORT WE'RE
WORKING ON WE FOUND THINGS THAT
SET OUT IN THE RISKS AND
PROTECTIVE FACTORS AND ROOT
CAUSES OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AMONG AMERICAN IN COMMUNITIES.
SO THERE ARE A LOT OF COMMON
THEMES ENVIRONMENTAL SCAN AMONG
AMERICAN INDIAN VICTIMS- THAT
WERE FAMILIAR TO THE TV NETWORK
AS WELL SO THIS DATA IS
IMPORTANT AGAIN LIKE I SAID TO
CREATE THIS POLICY CHANGE BUT WE
ALSO NEED TO- INCREASE WE'VE
SEEN AN INCREASE. IN
HOMELESSNESS- FOR INDIGENOUS
WOMEN ESPECIALLY DURING THIS
TIME OF COBIT YOU SEEN THAT
THERE NEEDS TO BE A LOT OF
FINANCIAL RESOURCES THAT ARE
NEEDED- WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF
FINANCIAL VIOLENCE THAT HAPPENED
WITH ARE WOMEN THAT HAVE BEEN-
HOMELESS BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO
STAY IN A- UNHEALTHY
RELATIONSHIP BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE HOUSING. OR A FAMILY TO
SUPPORT THEM THERE'S BEEN AN
INCREASE IN- TRAFFICKING AMONG
OUR- NATIVE PEOPLE HEARING
CALIFORNIA DURING THIS TIME A
COVE IT WE'VE ALSO SEEN. AN
INCREASE IN THE VIOLENCE AGAINST
OUR NATIVE WOMEN BY OUR OWN
NATIVE PEOPLE. SO IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT- WE EDUCATE A LOT OF OUR
CITY AND COUNTY PARTNERS AND SO
THAT'S ONE OF THE GOALS THAT
SECRETOS IS REALLY ENCOURAGING
OTHER COMMUNITIES TO PARTNER
WITH THEIR CITY AND COUNTY
OFFICIALS TO CREATE BETTER
RESOURCES- WE'VE PARTNERED WITH-
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
IN SAN FRANCISCO WE MET WITH
THEM ABOUT IDENTIFYING OUR
NATIVE POPULATIONS WE ALSO HAVE
A NATIVE TASK FORCE WITH THE SAN
FRANCISCO POLICE DEPARTMENT TO
ADVISE AND WORK WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT- EDUCATING THEM ON
AMERICAN COMMUNITY MMI P.
TRAINING FOR CULTURAL HUMILITY-
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT FOR US TO
PARTNER WITH OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND CREATING THESE TASK FORCE.
SO THAT THEY'RE HEARING FROM THE
NATIVE ADVOCATES. WE ALSO-
CONTINUE TO EDUCATE OUR CITY
OFFICIALS THROUGH PUBLIC HEALTH
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT IN MY P. IS
AN EPIDEMIC BUT IT'S ALSO A
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE. AND THAT'S
TAKING OVER URBAN AND TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES. OUR ADVOCATES ARE
ALSO WORKING WITH THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT TO EDUCATE THEM ON MMI
P. AND TRAFFICKING AMONG YOUNG
GIRLS ADDRESSING SEXUAL VIOLENCE
IN SCHOOL. WE WORKS- HAS BEEN
WORKING ON A HEALTH RESOLUTION
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH IN SAN FRANCISCO- IN THE
HUMAN RIGHTS COMMISSION FOR
RECENT ETHNIC DATA STANDARDS FOR
SAN FRANCISCO CITY AND COUNTY. A
SICKLY IS ALSO WORKING WITH THE
START OF JUSTICE FOR INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE TO CREATE A GUARANTEED
INCOME PILOT PROGRAM THIS IS THE
FIRST EVER- OF ANYTHING THAT
I'VE HEARD- AND THIS IS GOING TO
PROVIDE STABLE INCOME FOR
SURVIVORS. SO THAT SURVIVORS CAN
CHOOSE THEIR OWN PLAN TO CARE
FOR THEIR OWN HEALING BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW A LOT OF OUR SURVIVORS
HAVE TO GO- TWO CLINICS TO SEE
SAY. THE CLINICIAN WHO MAY NOT
BE A TRADITIONAL PERSON SO
THEY'LL SEEK TRADITIONAL HEALING
OUTSIDE IN THIS WAY THEY'LL BE
ABLE TO- CREATE OUR OWN PLANET
KERR WITH THIS OF. A GUARANTEED
PILOT INCOME PROGRAM. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'VE SEEN AMONG OUR
SURVIVORS ESPECIALLY THROUGH
THIS DATA REPORT IS. IS ASKING
FOR MORE TRAINING FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT- A LOT OF OUR
SURVIVORS ARE AFRAID TO COME
FORWARD OR CALL THE POLICE WHEN
SOMETHING HAS HAPPENED BECAUSE
OF. THE STEREOTYPES THAT HAPPEN
OR THE WAY THEY ARE TREATED- BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT SO IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
HAVE THAT TRAINING AND THAT
THESE TRAININGS MUST INCLUDE
INFORMATION ON HOW TO
ACCURATELY- WORK WITHIN OUR
INDIAN COMMUNITIES. AND ALSO
DOCUMENT- VICTIMS RAISED THEIR
TRAVEL FILIATION AND- JUST
HAVING THAT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
BACKGROUND INTO BEING TRAUMA
INFORMED TO WORK WITH THEM IN A
GOOD WAY. ALSO WE ASK FOR
MANDATED REPORTING TO OUR TRIBAL
NATIONS AND REPORT OF ANY
HOMICIDE OF MISSING PERSONS IF
THEIR TRAVEL CITIZEN OR
AFFILIATED- MAKING SURE THAT OUR
TRIBES ARE- AT THE FOREFRONT
INVOLVED IN THESE CONVERSATIONS-
WE ASK FOR. YOU KNOW MAKING SURE
THAT THE FUNDING IS FOR- THESE
EFFORTS FOR MMI P. EFFORTS ARE
INDIGENOUS ORGANIZATIONS AND
THAT THE TRIBES ARE OFTEN
BEARING THE BRUNT OF THESE COSTS
AND ALSO OUR- OUR LOCAL
GRASSROOTS ORGANIZATIONS. YOU
KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF COST FOR
FLYERS AND BILLBOARDS AND TRYING
TO ORGANIZE PEOPLE TO GET OUT
AND LOOK FOR OUR RELATIVES. IN
IT COSTS A LOT OF MONEY WE YOU
KNOW WE KNOW GAS IS SO EXPENSIVE
BUT TRYING TO GET PEOPLE TO COME
TOGETHER AND LOOK FOR THE
RELATIVES SAY FOR EVEN IN SAN
FRANCISCO CAN BE VERY DIFFICULT.
BUT CREATING FUNDING SO THAT SO
THAT WE CAN- PAY FOR THOSE COSTS
. CREATING A RESOURCE CENTER. OF
VICTIMS RESOURCE CENTER FOR
MISSING AND MURDERED INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE- IN FAMILIES IN
CALIFORNIA IS SO NEEDED THIS
CENTER COULD BE COULD PROVIDE.
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT CRISIS
ASSISTANCE TEMPORARY ASSISTANCE
WITH LODGING FOR FAMILIES WHO
ARE TRAVELING FROM OUT OF THE
AREA TO LOOK FOR THEIR LOVED
ONES. A RESOURCES FOR AT RISK
INDIGENOUS YOUTH A LARGE PORTION
OF MMI P. CASES IN CALIFORNIA
ARE TEENS AND CHILDREN AND
REQUESTING DEVELOPMENT OF
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT SERVICES FOR
AT RISK INDIGENOUS. USED TO
BETTER PROTECT THEM. AGAIN GOING
BACK TO THE TASK FORCE THAT IS
SO CRUCIAL I THINK IN OUR TRAVEL
COMMUNITIES IN URBAN COMMUNITIES
CREATING THIS STATE WORK
STATEWIDE TASK FORCE. WHICH
INVOLVES A NATIVE WAYS NATIVE
FAMILIES INDIGENOUS SURVIVORS.
OF TRAFFICKING AND PARTNERING
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE WE
HAVE TO WORK TOGETHER WE HAVE TO
BE ON THE SAME PAGE. AND I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT- YOU KNOW ALL
OF THESE- SUGGESTIONS OUT- I'VE
SHARED TODAY A REALLY A PART OF
THE HEALING AND- THIS
CONVERSATION IS A PART OF THAT
HEALING IT'S BRINGING US
TOGETHER. SO THAT WE CAN COME
TOGETHER AND IN HERE WHAT WE
NEED TO DO TO HEAL OUR
COMMUNITIES TO FILL OUR PEOPLE
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
TO- ASSEMBLY MEN- RAMOS AND
EVERYONE HERE. AND JUST
APPRECIATE BEING ABLE TO SIT ON
THIS PANEL WITH- THESE
CALIFORNIA INDIAN WOMEN LEADERS
HERE TODAY SO THANK YOU ALL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. NEXT WILL GO TO-
CHAIRWOMAN JANET BILL OF THE
PICAYUNE RANCHERIA OF THE CHANCE
THE INDIANS. HELLO HILLI HILLI
AND GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRPERSON
RAMOS CHAIRPERSON GARCIA. AND
MEMBERS OF THE NATIVE AMERICAN
CAUCUS WOMEN'S CAUCUS. AND THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON NATIVE
AMERICAN AFFAIRS. MY NAME IS
JANET K. BILL I AM THE CHAIR
PERSON FOR THE PICKING RANCHERIA
OF THE CZECH CHANCY INDIANS
WHICH IS A FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED
INDIAN TRIBES LOCATED IN COARSE
GOLDCALIFORNIA. IT IS AN HONOR
FOR ME TO BE HERE TODAY
REPRESENTING MY PEOPLE. TO SHARE
PERSPECTIVES ON A SUBJECT THAT
IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO THE
LIVES AND FAMILIES OF ALL
INDIGENOUS PERSONS. HOLDING THIS
PUBLIC HEARING IS A GOOD FIRST
STEP IN SHINING THE LIGHT ON THE
VIOLENCE AGAINST INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE. HOWEVER WE MUST NOT STOP
HERE. WE NEED TO ENSURE WE BUILD
ON TODAY'S MOMENTUM TO HAVE
ACTIONABLE ITEMS TO SOLVE THE
SYSTEMIC PROBLEM FOR THE FUTURE
. THE VIOLENCE AGAINST NATIVE
AMERICANS IS A DEADLY EPIDEMIC
AFFECTING OUR MOST VULNERABLE IN
OUR TRIBAL AND SURROUNDING
COMMUNITIES. AND THE CONCLUSION
THAT THE PROBLEM RISES TO A
LEVEL OF AN EPIDEMIC STATUS
COMES NOT ONLY FROM THE DATA.
BUT FROM WHAT TRIBES OF ALL
SIZES ARE DOING TO ORGANIZE AND
EDUCATE THEMSELVES AND OTHERS.
ABOUT THIS EPIDEMIC. BECAUSE
FRANKLY DATA IS INCOMPLETE AND
INACCURATE AND DOES NOT EVEN
GIVE JUSTICE TO THE TRUE SCALE
OF THIS CRISIS. TRIBAL LEADERS
ARE STANDING READY TO PARTNER
WITH THE LEGISLATOR AND THEN
MINISTRATION TO MOVE FORWARD A
NUMBER OF POLICIES THAT ROOTS
OUT AND ENDS VIOLENCE TOWARDS
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE. MY TRIBE HAS
WORKED TO ADDRESS THIS CRISIS BY
AMENDING OUR CIVIL LAW AND ORDER
ORDINANCE TO PROVIDE HARSH OVER
HARSHER PENALTIES FOR THOSE WHO
COMMIT ACTS OF VIOLENCE WITHIN
OUR JURISDICTION. STRENGTHENING
OUR LEGAL DEPARTMENT BY
ESTABLISHING AN ATTORNEY GENERAL
POSITION WITHIN OUR GOVERNMENT
STRUCTURE. PARTNERING WITH OUR
LOCAL PUBLIC OFFICIALS TO
ADDRESS THE JURISDICTIONAL GAPS
WE FACE AND BY INCREASING
EDUCATION AWARENESS INITIATIVES
FOR OUR TRIBAL MEMBERS. TODAY WE
ASK THAT YOU CONSIDER THE POLICY
FOLLOWING POLICY ACTIONS ONE
CREATE A BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION
A STAKEHOLDERS TO VELOP A LONG
TERM AND COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY
TO ADDRESS THIS CRISIS
HOLISTICALLY. RIGHT NOW THERE'S
NO ONE IN STATE GOVERNMENT
PRIMARILY DOING THIS WORK. TO
EMPOWER AN OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AGENCY. THAT WILL
MAKE SURE THAT SOLUTIONS ARE
IMPLEMENTED TO CURTAIL OR RADIC
KATE THE PROBLEMS. THREE
ESTABLISH A STATE WIDE ALERT
SYSTEM FOR MISSING AND MURDERED
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE. BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY PARTNER WITH TRIBES.
VICTIMS RIGHTS ADVOCATES LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND OTHER KEY
STAKEHOLDERS OUR VOICES MUST BE
HEARD TO ADEQUATELY ADDRESS THIS
CRISIS AS WE ARE CURRENTLY
ADVOCATING FOR CHANGE. YOU HAVE
HEARD AND WILL CONTINUE TO HEAR
FROM PEOPLE WHO ARE ON THE FRONT
LINES OF THIS ISSUE. WE ARE
COURAGEOUS AND DEDICATED PEOPLE
FROM ORGANIZATIONS WHO GIVEN THE
VOID AND OUT OF NEED. HAVE ACTED
ON OUR OWN TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEMS WE ARE CONFRONTED WITH
. SPEAK WITH US CONTINUE THE
DIALOGUE. EXAMINE AND LEARN FROM
OUR WORK OUR PROGRAMS AND OUR
PEOPLE. CONSIDER IMPLEMENTING
OUR LOCAL PROGRAM STATEWIDE SO
OTHERS CAN BENEFIT FROM THE WORK
THAT WE HAVE DONE. TAKE STOCK OF
ALL THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE OUT
THERE FIGHTING THE GOOD FIGHT
AND MAKING A DIFFERENCE. AND
ASSESS IF ALL THE PROGRAMS
TOGETHER ADDRESS THE NEED. IF
THERE ARE GAPS IN THE AREAS
CURRENTLY COVERED LET'S WORK
TOGETHER TO FIND SOLUTIONS TO
PLUG THOSE GAPS TO ENSURE THAT
ALL INDIGENOUS PEOPLE ARE
COVERED. I AM STANDING READY TO
NOT ONLY KEEP THE DIALOGUE GOING
READY TO ROLL UP MY SLEEVES TO
GET WORK DONE. AND WORKED
TIRELESSLY WITH YOU AND OTHER
KEY STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THAT
THIS HAPPENS. THIS IS AN ISSUE
THAT WILL TAKE EVERY SINGLE ONE
OF US. TO COME TOGETHER AND
SOLVE. THEREFORE IT IS INCUMBENT
UPON TRIBES THE STATE OTHER KEY
STAKEHOLDERS TO PARTNER AND WORK
TOGETHER. TO MAKE THIS SILENT
EPIDEMIC A TOP PRIORITY AND GIVE
IT THE ATTENTION OUR PEOPLE
DESERVE. THIS HEARING IS THE
FIRST STEP TO THE CALL OF ACTION
TO ELEVATE AWARENESS. MOTIVATE
OTHERS AND BUILD MOMENTUM TO
CONTINUE OUR ADVOCACY. AND
ENCOURAGE OTHERS NOT TO STOP
UNTIL WE ARE SUCCESSFUL. THANK
YOU FOR AFFORDING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY. AND THANK YOU FOR
PROVIDING THE PLATFORM TO RAISE
AWARENESS ABOUT THE SILENT
EPIDEMIC. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH ALL OF
YOU AND COLLABORATIVE LEE
ADDRESSING AND PREVENTING CASES
OF MISSING AND MURDERED
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THAT TESTIMONY AND- SOLUTIONS-
BEING PRESENTED TO THIS BODY
THANK YOU- CHAIRWOMAN BILL FOR
IT FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. NEXT
WE'LL MOVE TO- CHAIRWOMAN REGINA
COULD LARA THE SHINGLE SPRINGS
BAND OF MIWOK INDIANS. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR ALMOST A MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
REGINA CUELLAR CHAIRWOMAN OF THE
SHINGLES RASH FOR SPRINGS BAND
OF MIWOK INDIANS. DRIVES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY HAVE LONG SOUGHT
SOLUTIONS TO THE EPIDEMIC OF
MISSING AND MURDERED PEOPLE FROM
THEIR COMMUNITIES ONE SUCH
SOLUTION UTILIZED BY MY TRIBE IS
A JOINT JURISDICTION COURT. IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN SHINGLE SPRINGS
BAND OF MIWOK INDIANS AND THE
SUPERIOR COURT OF EL DORADO
COUNTY MADE HISTORY BY
ESTABLISHING THE FIRST JOINT
JURISDICTION COURT IN THE STATE
AND THE SECOND IN THE COUNTRY.
IT WAS NAMED THE FAMILY WELLNESS
CORE. THE COURT HAS TO JUDGES
ONE FROM EACH COURT HEAR CASES
INVOLVING CHILD WELFARE
SUBSTANCE ABUSE. JUVENILE
DELINQUENCY AND TRUANCY. BY
HEARING CASES ALONG THE COUNTY
THE TRIBE HAS ACCESS TO CASE
INFORMATION THAT WE OTHERWISE
WOULD NOT HAVE WITH THIS
INFORMATION TO TRY PROVIDE
HOLISTIC AND CULTURALLY BASED
CARE PLAN FOR THE CAR PURCHASE.
THIS PLAN HELPS IDENTIFY AND
PROVIDE SOLUTIONS FOR RISK
FACTORS THAT COULD LEAD THE
COURT PARTICIPANT INTO BECOMING
A MISSING OR MURDERED.
INDIGENOUS PERSON THE COURT
JUDGES AND THEN HOLD THE
PARTICIPANT ACCOUNTABLE FOR
FIFTY FOUR FOR FILLING THE CASE
PLAN THROUGH THIS JOINT PROCESS
OUR PARTICIPANTS HAVE GREATER
HAVE EXPERIENCE GREATER SUCCESS.
THAN THOSE WHO HAVE GONE THROUGH
JUST A TRIBAL OR STATE COURT
SYSTEMS DO THIS DUE TO THE
SUCCESS OF THE FAMILY WELLNESS
COURT JUSTICE YEAR THE TRIBE
SIGNED TWO AND WILL USE WITH THE
COUNTY TO EXPAND THE COURTS
SERVICE. TO INCLUDE A
COORDINATED DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
COURT AND A DRIVING UNDER THE
INFLUENCE PROGRAM. I WANT TO
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
ENCOURAGE INCREASED SUPPORT FOR
FUNDING JOIN JURISDICTION COURTS
AN INVALUABLE TOOL FOR
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE DESPERATELY IN
NEED OF THE HEALING AND HOLISTIC
APPROACH THIS COURT PROVIDES. ON
THIS DAY DEDICATED TO CREATING
AWARENESS OF MISSING AND
MURDERED INDIGENOUS PEOPLE I'D
LIKE TO COMMEND SHINGLE SPRINGS
TRIBAL COURT CHIEF JUDGE
VICTORIA SHAW HIS COMMITMENT AND
SERVICE TO THE FAMILY WELLNESS
COURT OR UN WAVERING. JUDGE
BECAUSE HUMBLY DEVOTED TO
ENHANCING THE SAFETY OF OUR
PEOPLE AND WE THANK HIM. WE ALSO
LIKE TO RECOGNIZE THE ARCHITECTS
OF OUR FAMILY WELLNESS CORE
HONORABLE CHRISTINE WILLIAMS
FORMER CHIEF JUDGE OF THE
SHINGLE SPRINGS TRIBAL COURT AND
THE HONORABLE SUZANNE KINGSBURY
CHOI PRESENT JUDGE OF THE
SUPERIOR COURT OF EL DORADO
COUNTY. THEY RECEIVED A NATIONAL
GRANT FROM THE BUREAU OF JUSTICE
ASSISTANCE TO CREATE THIS
COLLABORATIVE COURT.
ADDITIONALLY WE MUST ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT TRIBES FACE UNFAIR BARRIERS
TO CRIME INFORMATION DATABASES
VS EIGHT NETWORKS ON THE FEDERAL
LEVEL THE TRIBAL ACCESS PROGRAM
TAP. IS AN AVENUE TO CRIMINAL
AND THAT INFORMATION MY TRIBE IS
FORTUNATE TO BE AMONG THE TRIBES
SELECTED FOR ACCESS TO TAP
HOWEVER THE VOID REMAINS STATE
PERMISSION TO BE A. KLUTZ THE
TRY ALSO RECOGNIZE THE NEED FOR
STATEWIDE MISSING ALERT FOR
INDIGENOUS. WE ARE NOT WE ARE AT
ANY. RISK TO GO. SO THE STATE
NEEDS TO AN INCREASED RESPONSE
OUT FIND US. ONE SUCH SOLUTION
WAS JUST SIGNED INTO LAW IN
WASHINGTON STATE CREATING THE
FIRST IN THE NATION STATEWIDE
ALERT SYSTEM FOR MISSING
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE. THE LAW
CREATES HOTLINE SYSTEM SIMILAR
TO THE AMBER ALERTS VIA SEAN
TAYLOR AND THE SILVER ALERTS.
THE SYSTEM WILL NOTIFY LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHEN THERE'S A
REPORT OF A MISSING INDIGENOUS
PERSON. IT WILL ALSO PLACE
MESSAGES ON HIGHWAY READER
BOARDS AND ON THE RADIO AND
SOCIAL MEDIA. AND WILL PROVIDE
HIM FOR AND WILL PROVIDE
INFORMATION TO THE NEWS MEDIA.
IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE CREATE
A SIMILAR HOTLINE SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU TERM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALMOST PROVIDING
US TO BE HERE TODAY YOU'VE BEEN
AN OUTSTANDING LEADER IN
BRINGING THIS CRITICAL ISSUE TO
THE FOREFRONT. MM IP IS
IMPORTANT NOT ONLY TO MY TRIBE
BUT TWO TRIBES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND THE NATION I
APPRECIATE YOU SHINING LIGHT ON
THE NEED TO REDUCE UNCERTAINTY.
REGARDING CRIMINAL JURISDICTION
AND IMPROVING PUBLIC SAFETY ON
TRIBAL LANDS. WE SUPPORT YOUR
INITIATIVE FOR FUNDING TO STUDY
CHALLENGES RELATED TO THE
REPORTING AND IDENTIFICATION OF
MISSING AND MURDERED NATIVE
AMERICANS IN CALIFORNIA.
ESPECIALLY WOMEN AND GIRLS THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH-
CHAIRWOMAN COOLER. THAT WOULD
BRING IT TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. WHILE
RUSSIA THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY ON A KIND OF BUILD OFF
OF THE LAST- RECOMMENDATION YOU
JUST MADE IT LOOK AT A CHAIR
OVER HERE SAID HEY I'M GONNA I'M
GONNA DO THAT BILL IS IN THERE
NOW I'M A DO THAT. HE GAVE ME
THE- GAME. SIDE A REAL QUICK
LIKE MY- YEAR. BUT BUT ON WHAT
WHAT DOES YOUR I WHEN I YOU A
QUESTION ABOUT THAT YOU WE M. WE
SEE THE RECOMMENDATION AND MAYBE
A DIFFERENT CIRCUMSTANCE BUT-
THIS LAST YEAR WE WERE WORKING
WITH VETERANS GROUPS. AND THEY
WERE RAISING THE SAME ISSUE THEY
SAID YOU KNOW THERE ISN'T AN
ALERT SYSTEM WHEN THERE ARE
VETERANS THAT GO MISSING YOU
HAVE. AN ALERT SYSTEM FOR-
ELDERLY IT'S A SILVER YOU HAVE
YOU KNOW THE AMBER ALERT FOR
CHILDREN AND THERE MAY BE
SEVERAL OTHERS. AND SO WE WERE
EXCITED AND MOVING IN THE
DIRECTION OF POTENTIALLY PUTTING
FORWARD LEGISLATION AS RELATED
TO- WHAT THEY WANTED TO CALL THE
GREENER FOR VETERANS. WE ROLLED
UP OUR SLEEVES AND WE STARTED
TALKING TO ACTUAL VETERAN
GROUPS. AND THERE WERE A LOT OF
CONCERNS ABOUT THAT. THEY WERE
CONCERNED AS IT RELATES TO
VETERANS WHO SUFFER FROM PTSD
AND OTHER MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
THAT THE MINUTE THAT WE PUT OUT
A NUMBER- LOOKING FOR A VETERAN
THAT THAT CAN ACTUALLY HAVE A
VERY. ADVERSE AFFECT. APPLES AND
ORANGES DIFFERENT POPULATIONS
DIFFERENT CIRCUMSTANCES. JUST
WONDERING IF THERE ARE ANY
THOUGHTS ON. ON PROS AND CONS OF
THE ALERT SYSTEM I CAN'T THINK
OF ANY. I THINK IT WOULD ALL BE
A VERY GOOD TO CREATE THE WORD
IS A SOMEONE IS MISSING- FROM
THE RESERVATION. BUT RIGHT AWAY
WE PUT THE BRAKES. RIGHT AWAY WE
PUT THE BRAKES ON THAT ISSUE
BECAUSE OF FROM SPEAKING TO- YOU
KNOW THE VETERANS DIRECTLY THEY
SAID. THAT MAY NOT BE A GOOD
IDEA RIGHT SO I DON'T SEE ANY
ANY- OTHER REASONS WHY NOT TO DO
THIS BUT I'VE JUST WILL I REALLY
LIKE THE IDEA THAT'S WHY BRING
IT UP AND- AND I THINK THAT'S
WHY THE CHAIRMAN CAME IN THE
STING CARE QUICK. THEY'LL RUN
WITH IT BUT WE'RE GOING TO WORK
IN PARTNERSHIP IN REGARDS. IT
DEFINITELY IS- ANYBODY WANNA TRY
AND I'LL JUST- QUICK SAY
SOMETHING QUICK- THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION- I SEE NOTHING BUT
PROS FOR IT I DON'T SEE ANY CONS
AND AGAIN IT COULD BE- SOME OF
OUR TRIBAL PEOPLE ARE VERY-
RELUCTANT TO TELL THOSE STORIES
BUT I THINK JUST- PUTTING ALERT
ALERT LETTING THEM KNOW THAT
SOMEBODY'S MISSING I DON'T SEE
ANY CONS TO THAT AT ALL AND
MAYBE MY OTHER. TRAVEL HOW ONCE
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
THERE MAY BE SOME NEGATIVES BUT
I'M WE CAN'T SPEAK FOR EVERY
INDIGENOUS PERSON HERE BUT THE
POSITIVES FAR OUTWEIGH THOSE-
AGAIN IT'S NOT NECESSARILY. FOR
THAT SPECIFIC INDIVIDUAL THAT
HAS GONE MISSING BUT ALSO THEIR
FAMILIES IT'S ANOTHER WAY TO
ALSO RELIEVE PRESSURE FROM THEM
THAT THEY'RE NOT ALONE WE HAVE A
STATEWIDE SYSTEM OUR STATE
LEGISLATORS. LEGISLATORS CARE
ENOUGH ABOUT THIS ISSUE TO
IMPLEMENT SOME TYPE OF ALERT SO
AGAIN IT'S NOT ONLY THE
PERSPECTIVE OF THOSE WHO HAVE
GONE MISSING BUT THEIR FAMILIES
. THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT-
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN SHARON
QUIRK-SILVA. I THINK ONE OF THE
AFFECT OF USES OF THE LURCH IS
THAT WE KNOW THAT- YOU HAVE THE
BEST CHANCE OF FINDING SOMEBODY-
THAT IS MISSING WITHIN THE FIRST
TWENTY FOUR TO FORTY EIGHT HOURS
AND THAT'S WHY IT HAS BEEN SO
EFFECTIVE SO I THINK IT WOULD BE
VERY POSITIVE. BUT I ALSO WANTED
TO THANK ALL OF YOU ON YOUR
TESTIMONY BECAUSE YOU DID INDEED
ANSWER SOME OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
THE FIRST PANEL THAT I HADN'T
HEARD ABOUT- NORMALLY THE CROSS
JURISDICTION BUT SOME OF THE
SOLUTIONS. AS WITH THE BLUE
RIBBON PANEL ON THE
ACCOUNTABILITY- AND ALSO STATE
WIRE ALERT THOSE ARE A VERY
SUCCINCT AND I THINK THEY'RE
VERY DOABLE SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- ASSEMBLY MEMBER REGINALD
SELECT YES I WANT TO THANK YOU-
NOT ONLY FOR HIS TESTIMONY BUT
BRINGING TO US- A SOLUTION- I
SERVE WITH ONLY IS CHAIR PUBLIC
SAFETY BUT I'M ALSO ON PUBLIC
SAFETY BUDGET. AND THE CHAIR
PUBLIC SAFETY BUDGET IS ALSO
CRISTINA GARCIA WHOSE TO CHAT
THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS.
WEST BLUE CREEK BUT AS THE BLUE
RIBBON COMMISSION YOU OVERSIGHT
AGENCY- THE SYSTEM WIDE EMERGING
SYSTEM OF. TRYING TO CREATE A
PARTNERSHIP TO TRY TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT OUTSIDE AGENCY OR
EVEN A JOINT JURISDICTIONAL
COURT YOU KNOW THE FAMILY
WELLNESS COURSES YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT. TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT
STATEWIDE WILL PROBABLY NEED
FUNDING- AND SO I WILL MAKE. AND
I WILL PROBABLY. I WILL MAKE A
COMMITMENT FOR THE CHAIR THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS THAT IF YOU COME
TO US THIS PRESS WOOD MAY
REVISE- IT MAY BE TOUGH BUT IF
YOU COME TO US. WITH KIND OF A-
A BUDGET REQUEST BUT WHAT YOU
THINK WE WOULD NEED TO MAKE IT
HAPPEN IS JUST A STARTED AND
STOPPED I GIVE YOU THIS EXAMPLE
WHEN I CAME ON IN TWENTY TWELVE-
THERE WERE VERY FEW- I'LL CALL
BOUTIQUE COURTS. THERE WERE ANY.
GIVEN OF COURSE THERE WERE DRUG.
HOMELESS COURTS WHEN IT GIVE
THAT THEIR PLASTER- NOW BECAUSE
WE PUT MONEY TOWARD. AND WE
FORCED TO DO JUST SYSTEM- TO
LOOK AT EVERYBODY SEPARATELY NOT
AS ONE BIG GROUP SO- IF YOU GET
TOGETHER. AND MAYBE EVEN TALK
WITH- TO CHAIRMAN DID COMMITTEE-
ABOUT WHAT YOUR NEEDS ARE AND
MAY WE CAN. QUICKLY TRY TO. IT'S
SERVER CAN MAKE THIS HAPPEN. IS
IT TAKES MONEY. OUT OF WITH YOU.
AND I'M NOT TRYING TO OUR MONEY
BUT WE HAVE A SAY EIGHT BILLION
DOLLAR SURPLUS BUT I'M JUST
PUTTING IT OUT THERE. AND- BUT
IT DID BUT YOU WON'T GET
ANYTHING OUT TO YOU ASK- THAT
THAT SO I'M JUST OFFERING THAT-
FROM DAY OF SEPT FIVE CHAIR
ANDREW AND MYSELF WHO SIT ON
BUDGET SO BY. THE END WE
DEFINITELY WILL THANK YOU- THANK%
YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT- ANY OTHER
COMMENTS FROM- COMMITTEE MEMBERS
. NOPE I THINK IT THANK YOU-
GERMAN JONES SAWYER BEFORE THAT
AND CRISTINA GARCIA WE'RE DOING
THIS HEARING OF IT ALL DAY IT
SAYS DAVID IS IN CONJUNCTION
WITH WOMEN'S CAUCUS SO
DEFINITELY- WILL MAKE
APPOINTMENTS- WITH- CHAIRMAN
REGGIE JONES SAWYER AND BRING
THOSE FORWARD. AND I THINK THAT
ONE OF THE TOPICS THAT WE COULD
TALK ABOUT- WHICH IS CAME UP
HERE AND REOCCURRING IS SOME
TYPE OF AN ALERT SYSTEM AND-
WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND
START THE DIALOGUE ON THAT WITH
THE FEATHER ALERT IS WHAT WE
COULD CALL THAT- EDUARDO- MY
GOOD FRIEND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA. OF FEATHER ALERT AS WELL
AS GETTING FUNDING FOR THAT TO
MOVE FORWARD I THINK IT'S
QUESTIONS AT- WHERE SOME OF RAN
INTO SOME OBSTACLES WITH TRYING
TO PUT SOMETHING FORWARD BUT-
CHAIRWOMAN- BILL SAID IT SO
ELOQUENTLY THAT THE PROS DO
OUTWEIGH THE CONS IN IN THE
SITUATION THAT'S HERE. SO WE
LOVE TO WORK- WITH ALL THOSE IN
OUR COLLEAGUES HERE TO START TO
MOVE OR AND DISCUSS THAT. OF. A
FEATHER ALERT HERE IN THIS OF
CALIFORNIA MISSING MURDERED.
INDIGENOUS WEAPON EMISSION.
MURDERED INDIGENOUS PERSONS AND
MISSING PERSONS- FROM. INDIAN
COMMUNITIES AND TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND MANY INDIAN
RESERVATIONS HAVE A POPULATION
THAT RESIDE ON THE RESERVATION.
BUT MANY- PHILLY RECOGNIZED
TRIBES HAVE POPULATIONS IS STILL
LIVE WITHIN THE URBAN.
COMMUNITIES AND ALL OF
CALIFORNIA INDIAN TRIBES- LIVE
WITHIN THE URBAN AREAS
THEMSELVES WE'VE ALSO HEARD-
FROM PRIOR TESTIMONY THAT GOING
FURTHER. INTO THE BOXES AT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND- PROSECUTORS ARE
CHECKING OFF AS FAR AS
IDENTIFYING NATIVE AMERICAN. BAR
THAT WOULD BE JENNIFER TRY THAT
THEY'RE ACTUALLY ROM YOUR-
BECAUSE SERRANO- WE- RIGHT- YUP
IT'S GOING A STEP FURTHER TRYING
TO IDENTIFY THOSE THAT WHICH
BECOMES A LEARNING EXPERIENCE AN
EDUCATIONAL. COMPONENT BUT WE DO
SEE THAT AND THEN THE COURTS
DON'T ASK A QUESTION ON THE
COURSESOMEONE BROUGHT UP
COURTS. AND IT DO WE ALSO SEE-
WHERE- WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AN
OLDER SYSTEM WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
COLLECTING THE DATA AND WORKING
WITH ATTORNEY GENERAL- FOR THE
PROSECUTION OF THOSE THERE BUT
THE COURTS CAME UP AND I KNOW
THAT- TRAVEL- GOVERN. CORSTENS
THERE. HOW COULD THE STATE
JUDICIAL SYSTEM IN TRIBAL COURTS
WORK TOGETHER- ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE- AS FAR AS-
TRYING TO BE PREVENTIVE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT. THE DATA IS BEING SHARED
WITH WITH LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO- INVESTIGATE THESE TYPES OF
SITUATIONS- I'M WHAT I LIKE TO
SAID. THE A LOT. I THINK JUST-
THE ACCESS TO THOSE
INFORMATIONAL DATABASES YOU KNOW
WHEN SOMEBODY GOES MISSING THE
TRIBE WILL BE ABLE TO HAVE
ACCESS TO. THE TAB FOR THE CLIPS
AND UNFORTUNATELY- AT THAT LEVEL
WE DON'T HAVE ACCESS INTO. I
BELIEVE I'M A KLUTZ I BELIEVE
I'M SAYING IT RIGHT- BUT WE DO
HAVE ACCESS INTO THE TAP- BUT I
BELIEVE MAYBE MORE ACCESS FOR
ALL TRIBES. NOT JUST- JUST VERY
FEEL AND LIKE I SAID WE'RE VERY
ONE OF THE VERY FEW TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THAT AND- THAT%
INFORMATION IS WHEN THERE'S
SOMEBODY THAT'S MISSING THAT
INFORMATION GOES DIRECTLY INTO
THAT DATABASE. AND IT GETS PUT
OUT TO ALL TRIBAL ENFORCEMENT
AND ON LAW ENFORCEMENT NOT ONLY
TROUBLE BUT STATE AND LOCAL
OFFICIALS AND I THINK AGAIN-
WHEN YOU WE LIVE IN A RURAL
AREA. THAT'S THE MOST VITAL TO
GET OUT THAT INFORMATION AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE- YOU KNOW HAVE.
OFFICERS AND HIGHWAY PATROL
LOOKING ON FREEWAYS- BUT I THINK
TO WITH THE COURTS I THINK-
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON A WE'VE BEEN REALLY
SUCCESSFUL HATS HOLD. ON AND I
JUST DOES IT WE DON'T HAVE THAT. SOMETHING HAS BEEN VERY
HELPFUL FOR US. THANK YOU ANY
ANY OTHER WITH WISH TO COME ON
YEAH I WANTED TO SHARE THAT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT. THAT THERE
BE A DATA SHARING AGREEMENT
BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
TRIBES AND YOU KNOW OUR- URBAN
INDIAN HEALTH ORGANIZATIONS
BECAUSE WE CAN'T JUST HAVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT HOLDING THE DATA. AS
WE HAVE TO IDENTIFY THAT THERE
STILL IS SOME DISTRUST THERE AND
UNTIL WE HEAL THAT UNTIL WE
BUILD THOSE PARTNERSHIPS THEN WE
CAN HAVE- YOU KNOW A LARGER
DATABASE THAT CAN- PROVIDE
SUPPORT TO TWO TRIBES IN INTO
EVERYONE. BUT I THINK THAT IT
WOULD BE GREAT IF WE WERE ABLE
TO SEE- PARTNERSHIPS WITH THIS
DATA SHARING SO THAT- WE CAN.
BECAUSE I THINK TOO THAT'S WHERE
THE TRAINING COMES BACK INTO IN
MAKING SURE THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
HAS THE TOOLS TO IDENTIFY NATIVE
PEOPLE AND WE SEE THAT EVEN
WITHIN ARGUES WHO ARE. SAY
MISSING A LOT OF TIMES- THEY
HAD. THEIR LOOKED AT AS A RUN
AWAY AND- IS EITHER
MISIDENTIFIED AND THEN THE NEXT
THING YOU KNOW THERE'S BEEN DAYS
AFTER GONE BY. AND THAT YOU
THEIR CHILD HAS BEEN TRAFFICKED
AND WE CAN'T FIND THEM SO I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
GO BACK TO THOSE BASIC OF-
TRAINING IT. AND CULTURAL
COMPETENCY IN JUST AND- JUST
PARTNERING IT AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE'RE BUILDING THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS. OF TRUST HERE
THANK YOU FOR THAT- CHAIRMAN
BILL. IN ADDITION TO WHAT'S BEEN
SET UP SO THAT THIS REMINDING
ANNA DAUNTING THAT TRIBES ARE
SOVEREIGN GOVERNMENTS AND MARK
WE HAVE INHERENT SOVEREIGNTY
WITHIN OURSELVES. A. B. WITH.
MENTAL WELL. THANK SO OVER
ISRAEL TO- THE SYSTEM AND
WHETHER THE BARRIER THERE IS-
PUBLIC LOT TO EIGHTY STATUES-
AND IF SO RIGHT IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT WE KIND OF LOOK
AT IN A ERY NARROW WAY FOR
PURPOSES OF COLLABORATIVE
COMMUNICATION SYSTEMS OR IS THE
MODEL OF JUST AT MEMORANDUMS OF
UNDERSTANDING- THE PREFERRED
METHOD OF ACTUALLY MOVING INTO
THAT DIRECTION I WOULD. IMAGINE
THAT UP AND DOWN THE STATE THE
RELATIONSHIP WITH WITH THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT WITH RIGHT
WITH LOCAL PD IS VERY DIFFERENT
YOU MAY HAVE SOME FOLKS
OPERATIVE YOU MAY HAVE OTHER
FOLKS THAT ARE NOT AND SO I'M
JUST WONDERING IF THERE IS A
SPECIFIC. NARAL FOCUS TYPE FIX
IS IN THE CLASS DISCUSSION WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT PUBLIC CLOUD TO
EIGHTY I DON'T KNOW- IF THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT YOU WOULD WOULD
HAVE MAYBE IT UNDERSTAND BETTER
YEAH THAT'S A REALLY GOOD
QUESTION- I KNOW IN OUR COUNTY
AND I AM AN INTAKE LIKE YOU SAID
IT'S DIFFERENT IN ALL COUNTIES
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU HAVE THAT
RELATIONSHIP IF YOU DON'T HAVE
THE RELATIONSHIP. A LOT HARDER-
WE DID- WE DO HAVE AND WILL USE
I DON'T THINK FAMILY YOU SHOULD
BE WE SHOULD HAVE THOSE EMMYS I
AGAIN I THINK THEY SHOULD BE
ABLE TO JUST WE SHOULD BE ABLE
TO HAVE ACCESS TO THAT
INFORMATION WITHOUT HAVING TO
AND- I'M FOR WE. A MAN I. YOU IS
WITH THE CLASS AND WHY NOT ABLE
TO GET ACCESS SO THAT'S A REALLY
GOOD QUESTION- BUT MAYBE- WITH
THE SHERIFF I'M NOT SURE IF HE'S
STILL HERE BUT MAYBE HE MIGHT
HAVE SOME INFORMATION ON THAT
I'D BE VERY INTERESTED IN
FOLLOWING UP WITH THAT- THIS
PARTICULAR CONVERSATION MIGHT MY
EXPERIENCE THE- TO TRIBAL YOU
KNOW WHAT GOVERNMENT WAS-
UNDERSTANDING PUBLIC LAW TO
EIGHTY WAS WORKING AS AN INTERN
FOR A FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBE
BACK HOME. AND THERE WAS AN
ATTEMPT TO TRY TO SHAKE THAT UP
BUT HERE'S AN EXAMPLE WHERE
THERE MAY BE AN NARAL- FOCUSED
AREA FOR THE FACT OF SHARING
INFORMATION AND DATA ON THIS
VERY SPECIFIC CATION OF SURE IT
WOULD BE APPLICABLES. A GIVEN
THAT THIS IS I'M STATION TODAY I
WOULD LOVE TO FOLLOW UP WITH
THAT GERMAN AND COLLEAGUES TO
SEE IF THERE'S SOMETHING THAT WE
CAN DO FROM A LEGISLATIVE
STANDPOINT. TO FREE UP WHATEVER
THE- THE BLOCKAGES. IN TERMS OF-THE SYSTEMS OF COMMUNICATION
BEING AVAILABLE TO OUR SOVEREIGN
NATIONS. OKAY AGAIN I THINK GO
TO- I THINK THE SHERIFFS ARE
VERY ON EDUCATED ABOUT WHAT
EXACTLY THAT IS AND I THINK
THERE'S A THEY'RE A LITTLE
SCARED BECAUSE THEY FEEL THEY'RE
THE THEY'RE THE LAW THE LAW ON
THE COUNTY AND WITH ANYBODY'S
TRIBAL POLICE HAVING ACCESS I
FEEL THAT THEY THERE'S A LITTLE
BIT OF A LITTLE WORRIED THEY'RE
SCARED THEY'RE SCARED I THINK
THAT'S WHY THEY DON'T ALLOW
ACCESS. ON THE STATE LEVEL.
EXACTLY NO JOGO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THE OTHER ISSUE WITH THAT
TOO IS NOT ONLY ACCESS SHARING
I'M DOING I'M A I'M A USE OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT BUT BECAUSE
WE ALSO HAVE MENTIONED FUNDING
YOU KNOW- ANOTHER ISSUE THAT
LIMITS ACCESS IS BROADBAND
ISSUES DO WE HAVE THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THAT IS NECESSARY FOR
TRIBES ANYTHING SUCH AS THAT
THAT WOULD ALLOW US ONCE
LEGISLATION IS INVOLVED IN
CREATES A EASIER PATHWAY TO US
TO HAVE ACCESS BUT JUST AS
TECHNICAL ISSUES THAT WE WOULD
ALSO NEED ASSISTANCE WITH. IN
CARRYING THAT OUT. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER. QUESTION SOME COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS I MAKE A
COMMENT. YES EXCELLENT HEARING
ON THE BROADBAND I'M CHAIR OF
THE COMMUNICATIONS AND
CONVEYANCE SO YOU HAVE THE RIGHT
PEOPLE HERE. RODRIGUEZ AND-
WORKING GROUP CHAIR AND THE
AUTHOR OF BROADBAND FOR ALL
THERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY RIGHT
NOW THIS YEAR AND WE ARE ALREADY
STARTING AYE I BELIEVE WITH AT
LEAST ONE TRIED. TO GET THEM. TO
COMPETE FOR STATEFUNDING IT'S
CALLED THE CASTS OF C. C. A. S.
F. GRANTED YOU CAN CONTACT MY
OFFICE QUIRK-SILVA- AND WE COULD
START TO- UP TO. TALK TO YOU
ABOUT HOW YOU APPLY BUT TRIBAL
LANDS ARE INCLUDED AND THERE'S
QUITE A BIT OF FUNDING FOR
BROADBAND ACCESS. LISTEN THANK
YOU THANK YOU UP FOR THAT AND
BROADBAND YOU HAVE TO THE MAIN
AUTHORS FOR THE BILLS THAT WENT
THROUGH THIS ASSEMBLY- WITH-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOMAN- WHERE
CURRY AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA WHO ACTUALLY PUT
IN THE BILL INCLUDING TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS- SO- YOU SEE HOW
THAT'S WORKING. AND WE ALSO HAVE
THE CHAIR OF A PUBLIC SAFETY
WITH US WHICH DIVES INTO- PUBLIC
LOT TO EIGHTY FOR SO LONG WE'VE
BEEN TRYING TO GET- THE POST THE
CERTIFICATION TECH DEAL TO BE
INCLUDED. WHEN YOU'RE- A
JURISDICTION CLOSE TO- A FEDERAL
INDIAN RESERVATION TO HAVE THAT
PART OF THE TRAINING TO
UNDERSTAND THOSE COMPLEXITIES-
MAYBE THERE'S FURTHER DIALOGUE
THAT WE COULD TALK ON THAT
ISSUE. ALSO BUT I WANT TO THANK
YOU. FOR COMING FORWARD AND
OFFERING TESTIMONY OF WHAT'S
TRULY GOING ON RIGHT WITHIN
INDIAN COUNTRY ON THESE ISSUES
AND THE REOCCURRING. THEME THAT
I'VE SEEN AND HEARD A MEDIA IS
ON THE STATE ALONE ALERT SYSTEM
AND OTHERS USE MISSING PERSONS
ALERT SYSTEM WHICH GOT ATTENTION
FROM- THE MEMBERS THAT ARE HERE
TODAY TO START UP THAT DIALOGUE.
AND AS WE MOVE FORWARD ON THE
FEATHER ALERT I SAID THAT THREE
TIMES RIGHT FEATHER ALERT. RIGHT
WE'RE GONNA START TO- DIALOGUE.
ON THAT- WELL YEAH. BUT IT WAS
BETTER THAN A GREENER THAT-
MICHAEL. HAD SO WE'RE GOING IN
THE RIGHT TO. RIGHT IT WHICH
GOES TO THE TASK FORCE THAT-
BLUE RIBBON- IN LOOKING FOR
SUPPORT FROM MY COLLEAGUES AS
FAR AS- HOW DO WE MOVE FORWARD
ON THAT BLUE RIBBON. COMMISSION
THAT'S BEING- REQUESTED AS FAR
AS A SOLUTION. MOVING FORWARD WE
WOULD LEAN ON OUR COLLEAGUES TO
HELP US ON. WHETHER THROUGH THAT
AND ESTABLISH THAT SODA THANK
YOU AS WE TRANSITIONED TO A
PANEL THREE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU. THE PANEL
THREE- THIS SERVICE. IT DEALING
WITH ISSUES A PREVENTION
INTERVENTION AND POLICY IDEAS.
WE HAVE- CHAIRMAN JOE JAMES OF
THE YUROK TRIBAL COUNCIL. WE
HAVE CHAIRWOMAN ERICA PINTO OF
THE HALL MOVE. INDIAN VILLAGE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND WE HAVE
CHAIRWOMAN SARAH DUSKY OF THE I.
OWN BAND OF ME WALK INDIANS TO
AFTER TESTIMONY. I WANT IN THE
END. SO GONNA GO AHEAD AND LEAVE
IT OFF WITH CHAIRWOMAN ERICA
PAINTER FROM HUMBLE THAN THE GO
THEN GO TO CHAIRPERSON CHAIRMAN
JOE JAMES OF EUROPE TRAVEL
COUNCIL AND THEN TO- CHAIRWOMAN
SARAH DUSKY OF THE I. OWN BAND
ME WALK INDIANS. ALL MORE YOU
CAN SWITCH IT UP ON A SYSTEM I
JUST. TOOK IT IS HIS DUTY PLAN.
HOW GOOD AND GOOD AFTERNOON- MY
NAME IS ERICA MARIE PINTO AND I
AM THE TRIBAL CHAIRWOMAN OF THE
HIMALAYAN VILLAGE OF CALIFORNIA
WHERE OF THE HONOR OF SERVING AS
THE CHAIRWOMAN- THANK YOU. TO
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
NATIVE AMERICAN CAUCUS AND THE
WOMAN CAUCUS- FOR THE INVITATION
TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY. I ALSO
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE MY TRIBAL
COUNCILS HERE IN THE BACK OF THE
ROOM WITH MY YOUTH TRIBAL
COUNCIL SO I APPRECIATE THEIR
SUPPORT HERE TODAY. IT'S TRULY
AN HONOR TO JOIN ALL OF YOU IN
RECOGNIZING MURDERED MISSING AND
MURDERED INDIGENOUS WOMEN. AND
GIRLS AWARENESS. I AM INCREDIBLY
HONORED TO SPEAK ALONGSIDE SUCH
DISTINGUISHED TRIBAL LEADERS AND
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS ISSUES SURROUNDING
MISSING AND MURDERED INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE. I'D LIKE TO ESPECIALLY
RECOGNIZE ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON THE ISSUE
AND HIS SINCERE AND PASSIONATE
COMMITMENT. TO MAKING SURE THAT
WE BRING AWARENESS TO THE STATE.
ABOUT THIS EPIDEMIC. SENATE
ACCOUNT THIS IS WORTH NOTING BUT
SADIO COUNTY IS HOME TO MORE
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES THAN
ANY OTHER COUNTY. AND THE
HIMALAYAN VILLAGE IS JUST ONE OF
THIRTEEN COMING AYE BANDS. WE
TAKE OUR RESPONSIBILITY
SERIOUSLY TO CREATE A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT. FOR TRIBAL MEMBERS
ARE CASINO EMPLOYEES AND
VISITORS. DUE TO OUR
RESERVATIONS CLOSE PROXIMITY TO
THE US MEXICAN BORDER WE HAVE A
HEIGHTENED AWARENESS OF HOW
SIGNIFICANT AND IMPACTFUL THIS
ISSUE IS ON OUR COMMUNITY AND
HOW CRITICAL IT IS TO URGENTLY
RESPOND TO INCIDENTS THAT MAY
OCCUR. WITH ONLY THIRTY MINUTES
BETWEEN OUR RESERVATION AND THE
U. S. MEXICAN BORDER WE ARE
DILIGENT IN OUR COMMITMENT TO
PREVENT HUMAN TRAFFICKING. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT EVERY MINUTE
COUNTS SO WE TAKE A PROACTIVE
APPROACH. FOR US PREVENTION
STARTS WITH EDUCATION. FIRST
WE'VE HELD MEETINGS WITH THE
SHERIFF AND OUR TRIBAL MEMBERS
OF ALL AGES ON THE ISSUE AND
STRESSED THE IMPORTANCE OF CYBER
SAFETY FOR THEMSELVES THEIR
FAMILY AND OUR COMMUNITY. THIS
MEANS FRANK DISCUSSIONS AND HOW
TO BE SAFE ON THE INTERNET AND
WIDER PORTENT THAT WE MONITOR
INTERNET USAGE AND PRACTICE
CYBER SAFETY. I HAVE MANY NIECES
NEPHEWS AND LIKE ALL OF US THEY
ENJOY THEIR DEVICES
TREMENDOUSLY. SO IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT WE ENGAGE IN
THESE OPEN DISCUSSIONS ABOUT WHY
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE KEEP OUR
PERSONAL INFORMATION PRIVATE.
USE CAUTION WHEN POSTING
PICTURES. AND DO NOT INTERACT
WITH PEOPLE THAT WE DON'T KNOW
PERSONALLY. WE NEED TO TEACH THE
SAFETY PRACTICES GENERATIONALLY
AS WE HAVE MANY FAMILIES WHERE
GRANDPARENTS. AUNTS AND UNCLES
ARE THE PRIMARY CARETAKERS OR
INVOLVED IN THE CARE OF OUR
CHILDREN. WE ALSO IMPLEMENTED A
POLICY REQUIRING OUR MEMBERS TO
INCLUDE THEIR FINGERPRINTS ON
THEIR TRIBAL ID'S. SO WE HAVE
IDENTIFIABLE INFORMATION SHOULD
THEY GO MISSING. SECOND WE
PROVIDE EXTENSIVE TRAINING FOR
OUR CASINO EMPLOYEES ON HOW TO
RECOGNIZE SIGNS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. WE TRAIN EVERYONE
FROM FRONT LINE EMPLOYEES TO
MANAGERS. WE HAVE HOSTED
MULTIPLE TRAINING EVENTS
ALLOWING EXPERTS TO DEMONSTRATE
AWARENESS IDENTIFICATION AND
PREVENTION STRATEGIES IN THE
WORKPLACE. FINALLY COLLABORATION
IS KEY IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WE
ARE FORTUNATE TO HAVE SEVERAL
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH A STRONG
HEARTED NATIVE WOMEN COALITION-
EVEN BY THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
KEELY LATIN. THE ENVELOP A
PROGRAM RUN BY WENDY SLATER
FORMER VICE CHAIR OF LAWYER
SOUTHERN INDIAN HEALTH COUNCIL
AND THE INDIAN HEALTH COUNCIL.
EACH WITH ALL OF PROTECTING OUR
AMERICAN INDIAN PEOPLE AND
PROVIDING MUCH NEEDED RESOURCES
TO OUR COMMUNITIES. EACH
ORGANIZATION IS IN CONTINUED
COLLABORATION AND COMMUNICATION
WITH LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES TO BUILD UPON TRUST AND
ENSURE THAT OUR TRIBAL COMMUNITY
IS PROTECTED TO THE FULLEST
EXTENT POSSIBLE. TOMORROW ON MAY
FIFTH SPEAKING OF SAN DIEGO
COUNTY IN THE MOST TRIBES. BUT
IT'LL BE THE SECOND TIME THAT
THEY ARE RAISING THE MMI W. FLAG
FOR THE SECOND TIME IN A ROW SO
I APPLIED SEND YOU COUNTY. IN
ADDITION TO PREVENT. THE
DEVELOPMENT OF POLICIES THAT
HELP US ADDRESS THIS ISSUE ARE
EQUALLY IMPORTANT. THE METHODS
THAT PERPETRATORS USED TO
CONTINUE TO OUR CONTINUING TO
EVOLVE SO WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
OUR POLICIES ARE DESIGNED TO
COMBAT THIS EVER CHANGING. ISSUE
THAT HAS PLAGUED INDIAN COUNTRY
FOR FAR TOO LONG. I WANT TO
COMMEND ALSO THE STATE OF
WASHINGTON WHICH WE FOR TODAY A
LOT ABOUT. THE ALERT FOR SIGNING
INTO LAW AN ALERT SYSTEM FOR
MISSING MURDERED INDIGENOUS
WOMEN AND PEOPLE. THIS IS A
RAPID WAY TO ALERT THE PUBLIC ON
OBJECTIONS AND POTENTIALLY SAVE
LIVES. THESE ACTIONS ALSO RAISE
AWARENESS AND HELP BUILD TRUST
WITH TRIBAL COMMUNITIES. THESE
COLLABORATIVE EFFORTS ACROSS
VARIOUS AGENCIES MEANS THAT WE
WILL ALL BECOME FIERCE
PROTECTORS AND ADVOCATES ON THE
FRONT LINES OF OUR COMMUNITY'S
FIGHT AGAINST SEX TRAFFICKING OF
OUR MOST VULNERABLE PEOPLE. THE
HUMBLE INDIAN VILLAGE SERVES AS
A PLACE FOR MY COMMUNITY TO
PRESERVE AND PRACTICE TO
HERITAGE AND CULTURAL TRADITIONS
OF OUR ANCESTORS. A REMAIN
COMMITTED TO BUILDING BRIDGES.
MAKING CONNECTIONS OUTSIDE THE
TRIBAL COMMUNITIES TO ACCOMPLISH
GOALS OF MUTUAL INTEREST. WHILE
ENSURING THE VOICES OF TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES ARE HEARD AND OUR
PEOPLE ARE PROTECTED AND KEPT
SAFE FOR GENERATIONS TO COME AND
MIGHT TAKE THIS FEATHER ALERT A
STEP FURTHER AND HOPEFULLY MAKE
IT A NATION WIDE AS YOU KNOW
THAT. UNITED STATES IS HOME TO
FIVE HUNDRED SIXTY FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBAL NATIONS. ONLY
THAT SENATE. WE ARE CLOSEST TO
THE U. S. MEXICAN BORDER WHETHER
YUROK TRIBE IS CLOSEST TO THE
STATE NEXT DOOR SO. IT'S VERY
IMPERATIVE THAT WE THOSE THOSE
HOURS ARE CRITICAL THOSE MINUTES
ARE CRITICAL THE COULD COST
LIVES AND AN ALERT SYSTEM.
NATIONWIDE WOULD REALLY HELP US
ALL. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TODAY THANK YOU- TO
BE- NEXT WILL BE GOING TO THEIR
JAIL J. ZERO NONE. WE ON HERE.
JOHN YEAH- THAT IS THE YOU THE
CHAIRMAN FROM SPEAK BEFORE I
BEFORE I START MY TEST OF. YOU
KNOW WHAT- A HEAVY HEAVY HERE
WE'RE TALKING TODAY WITH THEIR
HEART A LOT OF EMOTION BUT HERE
TODAY WE'RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT
SOLUTIONS AND ACTIONS BUT BEFORE
I OPEN UP MY TESTIMONY ABOUT
OPEN UP WITH. THE PRESS.
COOL COOL- OKAY- COOL COOL THANK
YOU- HEY YOU.
WHO WHO WE HAVE WORK LEFT. EIGHT
GIVE US A GOOD AFTERNOON- MY
NAME'S ADJUSTED J. SOME CHEN THE
EUROPE A COMPANY VILLAGE OF
STRUGGLING ON THE LOWER KLAMATH
RIVER YOU KNOW I AM HONORED HERE
TO BE HERE TODAY DISCUSS THE
MISSING AND URGES PEOPLE CRISIS
YOU CAN HEAR SOME OVERLAP HERE
ON MY TESTIMONY HERE. YOUR
TRAVIS IS A VITAL CULTURAL
POLITICAL LEADER IN OUR REGION
AND OUR TROUBLE COUNCIL COURT
ARE INTERNATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
FOR DEVELOPING HOLISTIC
APPROACHES FOR PEOPLE FAMILIES
IN OUR COMMUNITY AT LARGE WE
CONDUCTED THREE YEARS OF
RESEARCH ON THESE MMO I W. P. IN
OUR REGION I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT A FRAMEWORK FOR
LEGISLATION ACTIONS THAT
LEGISLATION. LEGISLATURE CAN YOU
TAKE. WE HAS TROUBLE KNOW THE-
AND FINANCIAL ARE IN NEED RESULT
CRISIS IN OUR COMMUNITIES WE
NEED THE CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT
THE LEGISLATURE IN OFFICE OF
GOVERNOR TO PART WITH US. WITH
THE FURTHER COMMITMENTS TO
PREVIOUS. TO PREVENT AND LIMIT
THIS CRISIS TO CONTINUE THE
GREAT WORK THEY'VE DONE ALREADY-
THAT SHARE. THE FRAMEWORK
INCLUDES. FIRST INITIAL LEADS TO
INCLUDE LEGISLATION ELIMINATE
SYSTEMIC BARRIERS TO TROUBLE
COMMUNITIES. ONE SECOND IS WE
NEED TO WE NEED SATE FUNDING
FOR TRIBES AND TRIBAL PEOPLE
FOCUSED ON A VIOLENCE PREVENTION
AND SOCIAL SERVICE. WITHIN
POLICY CHANGE AND REFORM WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED SOME OF THE KEY AREAS
FOR ROOF FOR REFORM. FIRSTLY
LEGISLATION ALLOW TRIBAL POLICE
IN TROUBLE COURTS TO PROTECT OUR
PEOPLE ENFORCE JUSTICE TO THE
FULL EXTENT LAW. STUDY HAS SHOWN
THAT PUBLIC SAFETY IMPROVE
IMPROVE ONE TRAVEL NATIONS HAVE
RESOURCE AND OF COURSE OUR OWN
LOSS AND PROTECT THEIR PEOPLE.
IN THE AREA AS REMOTE AND RULE
AS A RESERVATION AND IN A PUBLIC
LOT TO EIGHTY STATE THAT IS THIS
IS CRITICAL. WE NEED LEGISLATION
THAT RECOGNIZED PROBABLY SUFFERS
AS PEACE OFFICE IN A CALIFORNIA
PENAL CODE. AS WELL AS
LEGISLATION THAT GRANTS ACCESS
TO TROUBLE COURTS IN TROUBLE
POLICE TO THE CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT TELEKI SYSTEM ALSO
KNOWN AS COLLECT. EXISTING
FEDERAL. THAT TRIBES. RETAINED
INHERENT SOVEREIGN AUTHORITY
OVER THERE IN INCOME IN THE
COUNTRY. THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IN THIRTEEN STATES. I RECOGNIZE
TROUBLE LONG COURSE AT THIRTY TO
WAR STATE AND FEDERAL LAW.
CALIFORNIA MUST PASS A LAW TO
RECOGNIZE TROUBLE POLICE AS
PEACE OFFICERS SO THAT WE CAN
ENFORCE OUR SOVEREIGNTY IN IN
THE LAW. SECONDLY THE
LEGISLATION THAT GRANTS TRUMP
POLICE OFFICERS AND TRIBAL COURT
ACCESS TO THE TO THE CALIFORNIA
LAW ENFORCEMENT TELL BECAUSE
THIS COMMUNICATION SYSTEM.
SECONDLY LEGISLATION IS TO
STRENGTHEN THE COUNTY SOCIAL
SERVICE RESPONSE WHEN INDIGENOUS
CHILDREN GO MISSING FROM FOSTER
CARE. WE KNOW THAT FOSTER CARE
IS SADLY A PIPELINE. THE MISSING
AND MURDERED ALL YOU NEED TO
MAKE AN CHILDREN ENTERING THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM AT A RATE%
OF TWO POINT SEVEN TIMES AND THE
REPRESENTATION IN THE POPULATION
THE HIGHEST OF ANY RACIAL GROUP
RIGHT NOW. WE DID NOT GET
NOTICED WHEN TRAVEL CHILDREN GO
MISSING FROM THEIR FOSTER CARE
DESPITE STATE GUIDANCE TELLING
COUNTIES OTHERWISE WE ALSO SEE
TIME AND TIME AGAIN. THAT ONE
FOSTER CARE COOPER FOSTER
CHILDREN GO MISSING FROM FROM
KERR COUNTY SOCIAL SERVICES DO
NOT FILE  POLICE TO FOR A
CONTACT THE POLICE DESPITE STATE
GUIDANCE STATING OTHERWISE
LEGISLATION IS NEEDED TO ENSURE
THE STEPS ARE TAKEN SO TRY TO
STEP IN AND TAKE CARE OF OUR
CHILDREN. WHO GO MISSING. YOU'VE
HEARD THIS WITHOUT THE DAY FIRST
NEED APPROVAL ALERT SYSTEM FOR
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE WHEN THEY GO
MISSING A SYSTEM LIKE THE ONE
JUST PASSED IN WASHINGTON STATE
. UNDER THAT NEW LAW WHEN IT I
PERSON IS REPORTED MISSING LAW
ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITY ALERT
RESULTING IN DETAILS ABOUT THE
PERSON BEING. BROADCAST VIA
HIGHLY DIVISOR RADIO MESSAGES
SCIENCE PRESS RELEASES FOR THE
MEDIA AS A TRIBE LOCATED IN A
RURAL COMMUNITY WHERE PEOPLE
LACK ACCESS TO TECHNOLOGY
INFORMATION AND IN A PUBLIC LAW
TO THIRTY EIGHT. TO THIRTY EIGHT
STATE WERE JURISDICTIONAL ISSUES
BRING UP CONFUSION WHEN PEOPLE
GO MISSING WE NEED AN IMMEDIATE
STATEWIDE ALERT. TO LOCATE THE
INDIVIDUAL AND APPROVED IN CASE
OF THE LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
IN LOCAL JURISDICTIONS. FINALLY
CERTAINLY NOT LEAST WHEN THEY
LEGISLATION INCREASE FUNDING FOR
TRIBAL PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
RESPONSE TO THIS TO THIS CRISIS.
THE FUNDING SHOULD BE HOLISTIC
AS DATA SHOWED THAT A RANGE OF
RISK FACTORS INCLUDING
HOMELESSNESS. MENTAL HEALTH
VIOLENCE AND VICTIMIZATION HUMAN
TRAFFICKING SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
TRANSITION FROM FOSTER CARE ARC
ARE ALSO BECAUSE OF THIS CRISIS
THIS LESLIE HAS A KEYPAD
CAPACITY TO BOOST REGIONAL
SERVICES WHICH ARE LACKING OR
NONEXISTENT FOR TRIAL WHEN AREA
OF HOUSING. MENTAL HEALTH
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS IN
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. WITH TRIBAL
LEADERS ARE READY TO EAGER
DEVELOP CULTURE RESPONSE OF
PUBLIC HEALTH UPSTREAM
PREVENTION APPROACHES. WE NEED
HOLISTIC AND COMPREHENSIVE
FUNDING IN THE YEARS TO COME.
TODAY I TRULY APPRECIATE. BEING
ABLE TO PROPRI TEST ME IN FRONT
OF YOU A CHAIR IN COLLEAGUES OF
I THINK WE'RE AT A POINT IN TIME
NOW FOR THE A LOT OF GREAT WORK
THAT YOU'VE DONE IN THE
COMMITTEE- WE'RE ALL IN THIS
TOGETHER. AS A VILLAGE WAS A
FAMILY R. R. IT HURTS. WHEN WE
HEAR OUR- ARE WOMEN. OUR
DAUGHTER OR CHILDREN OR NIECES
YOU KNOW- IT IT IT HURTS WHEN
BEING HELPLESS NOT BE ABLE TO
HELP. AND AGAIN WE'RE GOING TO
KEEP DOING THE GREAT WORK THAT
WE DO AND TO HELP OUR OUR PEOPLE
BACK AT HOME. I THINK WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY. NOT ONLY TO PICK IT
BACK TO THE WORK THAT WASHES
STATE BUT ALSO LEAD AS A STATE
OF CALIFORNIA TO IMPROVE ON
THAT- AND SO AGAIN. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME HERE TODAY BAKULA
THANK YOU THANK YOU- RESEARCHER. ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA IS VERY
QUICKLY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY I'VE GOT YOUR SKIS
MYSELF. ME WITH A GERMAN-
TORTOISE- FROM TM TOWARDS
MARTINEZ WAS IN TOWN. AND AND
DEAL WITH SOME DISTRIBUTION I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR TO SOMEONE
YOU'VE ANSWERED. SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS REGARDING THE BARRIERS
THAT BUBBLE AUTOMATE THINGS SO-
MISTER TESTIMONY BUT WE HAVE A
MEMBER OF OUR TEAM LISTENING-
VERY CLOSELYAND- WE JUST WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU. LET'S CHECK IN
IN IN SOME REGARDS  REAL QUICK
RELIEF- COLLECTS IT- THAT'S
SIMPLY IN THE PEACE OFFICER
THAT'S SOMETHING WE CAN DO. THAT
DOESN'T IN MY OPINION- IMPACT TO
THE PUBLIC LAW TO EIGHTY I THINK
THAT COULD BE DONE PERFECT I
LOOK FOR TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MUCH OF. GARCIA
WILL MOVE NOW TO CHAIRWOMAN
SARAH DUSKY OF THE I. OWN BAND.
ME WALK INDIANS. ALL RIGHT WELL
GOOD AFTERNOON- THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS- MEMBERS
OF THECALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
NATIVE AMERICAN CAUCUS THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS AND THE ASSEMBLY
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR ATTENTION
TODAY- ASSEMBLY REMEMBER ALMOST-A SAID I'M SCARED THAT KEY AND
I'M HERE TODAY IN MY CAPACITY AS
CHAIR WOMAN FROM MY TRIBE. DIO
BAND TO ME WALK INDIANS LOCATED
NOT TOO FAR FROM WHERE WE SIT
TODAY AND THIS IS OUR ABORIGINAL
HOMELAND ALONG WITH MY FELLOW
LEADER HERE- CHAIRPERSON
CUELLAR. MUSCLE PRACTICING
ATTORNEY AND FEDERAL INDIAN LAW-
AS YOU KNOW AS A. THIS ISSUE
HITS HOME FOR ME BOTH AS A
PRACTICING ATTORNEY WHO'S BEEN
TASKED WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF PUBLIC BY TWENTY FOR CLIENTS
IN MY OWN TRIBE- SINCE I STARTED
PRACTICING AS A TRIBAL LEADER
WHO'S TASKED WITH ENSURING THE
CONTINUED WELL BEING OF
GRANDMOTHERS MOTHERS AUNTIES- OF
NIECES AND REALLY ALL OF OUR
TRIBAL CITIZENS AND AS AN
INDIGENOUS WOMAN WHO MIGHT OFF
AT A VERY YOUNG AGE LOST ONE OF
MY CLOSEST FRIENDS AND FAMILY
MEMBERS. TO THIS EPIDEMIC. SO
IT'S REALLY AN HONOR. TO BE HERE
TALKING TO YOU ABOUT THIS TODAY
AND REPRESENT MY PEOPLE AND TO
OFFER CLOSING REMARKS I'M FOR
THIS VERY IMPORTANT HEARING. C.
HEARD FROM A LOT OF MY STEAM
COLLEAGUES- AND FOLKS WHO ARE
WORKING HARD ON THIS ISSUE-
THEY'VE GIVEN VERY INFORMATIVE
AND COMPELLING TESTIMONY SO I'M
GONNA TRY TO KEEP MY IN SHORT
THOUGH- YOU'LL HEAR A LITTLE BIT
OF REPETITION. REPETITION IS
GOOD BECAUSE WE WANT TO HAMMER
THE- THE MESSAGE HOME AND MAKE
SURE THAT WE ALL WALK AWAY WITH
THAT VERY STRONG MESSAGE- AND
REALLY TAKE ACTION. THOSE THEIR
PROVIDED TESTIMONY TODAY HAVE
MADE SOME VERY COMPELLING
REASONS FOR YOU AND OTHER STATE
LEGISLATORS. TO TAKE ACTION AND
A FEW VERY CRITICAL WAYS AND
I'VE KIND OF SUMMER SUMMARIZE
THEM INTO THREE- THREE DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES FOR A WALK THROUGH.
FIRST YOU'VE BEEN URGED TO KEEP
THE DIALOGUE GOING TO KEEP THE
HEARINGS GOING AND TO KEEP THE
EDUCATIONAL AWARENESS GOING.
THAT CONTINUE DIALOGUE IS
IMPERATIVE TO RESOLVING THIS
CRISIS WE MUST KEEP
INVESTIGATING WE MUST KEEP
WORKING TO IDENTIFY THE
UNDERLYING CAUSES AND UNDERSTAND
pJUST THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA'S
INDIAN COUNTRY BUT THROUGHOUT
THE STATE AS A WHOLE BECAUSE AS
SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES IS
TESTIFIED TO YOU BEFORE TO.
TODAY SOME OF OUR INDIGENOUS
WOMEN AND- MEMBERS ARE GOING
MISSING FROM URBAN AREAS NOT
JUST RESERVATION OR RURAL AREAS
. THE LEGISLATURE HAS THE POWER
AUTHORITY AND THE PLATFORM TO
DRILL DOWN AND IDENTIFY AND
DEVELOP PROGRAMS TO RESOLVE THIS
CRISIS AND TO DEVELOP PROCESSES
TO EVALUATE HOW EFFECTIVELY
THESE PROGRAMS ARE ADDRESS IN
THERE CRISIS ON AN ONGOING BASIS
SO WE CAN'T JUST ADOPT PROCESSES
AND WALK AWAY FROM THE ISSUE
THIS IS GOING TO BE ITERATIVE
IT'S GOING TO BE ON GOING. AND
IT NEEDS TO BE DYNAMIC. YOU THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE AND WE
TRIBAL LEADERS HAVE THE POWER
AUTHORITY AND I'D ARGUE THE
DUTY. TO CALL ON OTHER TRIBAL
NATIONS GOVERNMENTOFFICIALS
ADVISED CÁC GROUPS EDUCATORS- TO
GET EDUCATED ON THE FACTORS THAT
CONTRIBUTE TO THIS CRISIS. PUT
SIMPLY WE CAN'T RESOLVE IT.
WITHOUT A KEEN UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT'S OCCURRING WHERE IT'S
OCCURRING HOW IT'S OCCURRING AND
WHY IT'S OCCURRING. HOLDING AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING SUCH AS
THIS ONE ON A MORE FREQUENT
BASIS WILL HELP TO ELEVATE
PUBLIC AWARENESS ABOUT THIS
CRISIS AND CONTINUE TO ENHANCE
ALL OF OUR KNOWLEDGE OF THE
ROLES RESPONSIBILITIES AND
COORDINATION THAT CAN SHOULD AND
MUST OCCUR BETWEEN TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO PUBLIC AGENCIES AS
WELL AS COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND VICTIM.
ADVOCACY GROUPS. IT IS ONLY FROM
THE FAT VANTAGE POINT THAT
BETTER INFORMED DECISION MAKING
. AND HAPPEN. AT THIS PARTICULAR
MOMENT IN TIME WITH ALL THE
ATTENTION TO THIS ISSUE I
BELIEVE THERE ARE VERY PROMISING
OPPORTUNITIES THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CAN CAPITALIZE UPON
TO ADDRESS THIS CRISIS TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS THE FOR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENTS OTHER STATES AS
WE'VE HEARD ABOUT TODAY AND
EXPERTS EXPERTS IN THE FIELD AND
THE BOOTS ON THE GOUND TACKLING
THIS ISSUE ON AN EVERYDAY BASIS
ARE COMMITTED TO RESOLVING THE
CRISIS AND READY AND WILLING TO
SERVE. THROUGH CONVERSATIONS AND
HEARINGS IN THE CAPITAL AND IN
EVERYBODY'S VARIOUS DISTRICTS
AND HOMELANDS. WE CAN IDENTIFY
SOLUTIONS AND BEST PRACTICES
THAT WILL MAKE TREMENDOUS
DIFFERENCE IN PROTECTING NATIVE
PEOPLES FAMILIES AND ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. THROUGH THOSE
CONVERSATIONS IN HEARINGS WE CAN
IDENTIFY THE GAPS THAT NEED TO
BE FILLED THROUGH THOSE
CONVERSATIONS IN HEARINGS WE CAN
EDUCATE ONE ANOTHER IN THE
PROCREATION SEASON DEPARTMENT
AND CALIFORNIA CITIZENS
GENERALLY. SO THAT WE CAN AVOID
BECOMING A STATISTIC OR HOW TO
RESPOND IF YOUR LOVED ONES ARE
SUBJECTED TO SUCH A CRIME. THE
SECOND POINT THAT RESONATED WITH
ME TODAY HEARING FROM FROM MY
COLLEAGUES. IS THAT POLICIES ARE
NEEDED. IMMEDIATELY TO PROVIDE
SHORT TERM RELIEF. THEIR
INDIVIDUAL EFFORTS PEPPERED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO ADDRESS
THE EPIDEMIC AND WE'VE HEARD
ABOUT MANY OF THEM TODAY THESE
EFFORTS CAN AND SHOULD BE
REPLICATED QUICKLY AND IN
EARNEST IN THIS REGARD THEIR
SURPLUS FUNDS IN THE STATE'S
BUDGET. AS A ONE ASSEMBLY
MANAGER MEMBERS MENTION TODAY
I'M NOT GOING TO FORGET THAT-
THAT CAN QUICKLY IT COULD BE
EXPANDED- TO IMPLEMENT MANY OF
THESE PROGRAMS. AND OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT ARE BEING OPERATED
STATEWIDE OR THAT SHOULD BE
OPERATED. AS WE LEARN WHAT WORKS
TO RESOLVE THIS CRISIS. PUTTING
IT SIMPLY WE ALL NEED TO WORK TO
FIX THE PLANE MID FLIGHT HERE
BECAUSE WE REALLY DON'T HAVE
ANOTHER OPTION- WE NEED TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT TRIBES PUBLIC
AGENCIES COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS ADVOCACY GROUPS
ALL THE GROUPS THAT WE'VE ALL
HEARD FROM TODAY GROUPS THAT
WE'VE ALL MENTIONED- TO COME UP
WITH THE SHORT TERM SOLUTIONS.
RIGHT NOW- I GUESS THE THIRD
CATEGORY- OF KIND OF POLICIES
AND IDEAS WE'VE HEARD ABOUT. OUR
STRATEGIES. THAT ARE AIMED AT
LONG TERM SOLUTIONS TO
ADDRESSING THIS CRISIS AND I.
ARE YOU MY PAPER HERE AS PEOPLE
ARE TALKING I MADE SCRIBBLES
EVERYWHERE AND I HOPE I CAN READ
IT WHEN I GO HOME- AT THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE YOU HAVE
THE POWER TO LEGISLATE A LONG
TERM STRATEGY HERE. AND WE CAN
HELP YOU. YOU'VE HEARD FROM
SEVERAL OF MYCOLLEAGUES TODAY
ABOUT SOME REALLY INCREDIBLE
IDEAS- AND GOTTEN SOME GREAT
ADVICE ON WHAT WE MIGHT BE ABLE
TO DO TO FIX THE SOLUTION LONG
TERM. MY FELLOW CHAIRPERSON-
BILL FROM CHUCK CHANCY SHE
MENTIONED THE CREATION OF A BLUE
RIBBON COMMITTEE. WHICH BUILDING
ON THE CURRENT WORK BEING
UNDERTAKEN BY DOJ AND THREE ZERO
NINE NINE THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS I'M COULD WORK TO
INVESTIGATE AND FULLY ASSESS THE
SCALE AND SCOPE OF THE CRISIS
FURTHER IDENTIFY THE UNDERLYING
ISSUES AND RECOMMEND BEST
PRACTICES AND SOLUTIONS TO
ESTABLISH THE GREATEST
OPPORTUNITIES TO PREVENT THE
ATROCITIES THAT ARE CONTRIBUTING
TO THIS EPIDEMIC ON AN ONGOING
BASIS. MY FELLOW CHAIRPERSON
REGINA CUELLAR FROM SHINGLE
SPRINGS. SHE MENTIONED SUPPORT
FOR CROSS JURISDICTIONAL COURT
ON A STATEWIDE BASIS THIS COULD
HELP BY ITSELF SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM BUT SO MANY PROBLEMS
THAT PLAGUE INDIAN COUNTRY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND HELP
RESOLVE SOME OF THE- MYSTERY AND
MISUNDERSTANDING. SURROUNDING
IMPLEMENTATION APPEAL TO EIGHTY
IN THE STATE. YOU'VE HEARD FROM
CHAIRWOMAN PENTA ABOUT WHAT
THEY'RE DOING ON THEIR
RESERVATION TO EDUCATE THEIR
YOUTH ABOUT RESPONSIBLE USE OF
THE INTERNET AND SOCIAL MEDIA
WHICH IS ACTUALLY QUITE
CRITICAL- AS WE MOVE FORWARD
PROGRAMS LIKE THAT CAN AND
SHOULD BE IMPLEMENTED ON A
STATEWIDE BASIS. YOU ALSO HEARD
FROM CHAIRPERSON JAMES ARE FROM
EUROPE WHO. STRONGLY RECOMMENDED
THAT THERE BE A KEEN EYE TOWARD
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM SO THAT
WE DON'T LOSE OUR CHILDREN
THROUGH THAT SYSTEM IT'S ALREADY
SUCH A BLOW TO OUR NATIVE
COMMUNITIES TO HAVE OUR CHILDREN
IN FOSTER CARE IN THE FIRST
PLACE. AND TO LOSE THEM TO THIS
EPIDEMIC IS EVEN MORE OF A
DIFFICULT HELLO. THESE ARE JUST
SOME EXAMPLES OF THE MYRIAD OF
WAYS IN WHICH THE LEGISLATURE
CAN WORK TO ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM
NOW. SO AS TO MAKE MEANINGFUL
PROGRESS TOWARD RESOLVING THIS
CRISIS IN THE FUTURE. WITHOUT A
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY AND PLAN
THE EFFORTS TO COMBAT THIS
CRISIS WILL BE INCOMPLETE AT
ULTIMATELY INEFFECTIVE. CURRENT
GAPS WILL REMAIN. NEW CAPSULE
FORM. AND THESE GAPS WILL BE
EXPLOITED WITH POTENTIALLY
CATASTROPHIC RESULTS. ONE THING
IS CERTAIN NOW FAILING TO ACT
WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE A HEAVY
HUMAN TOLL. I ASK THAT YOU I ASK
YOU A WHAT OTHER PUBLIC POLICY
ISSUES BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE
ARE CRITICALLY IN NEED OF
RESOLUTION. AS THAT OF MISSING
AND MURDERED INDIGENOUS PEOPLES. INCLUDING I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR AFFORDING ME THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS HEARING
AND I URGE YOU TO BUILD UPON
TODAY'S DISCUSSIONS TO KEEP THE
DISCUSSIONS GOING INTO IMPLEMENT
SHORT TERM AND LONG TERM
STRATEGIES AND POLICIES AS
NECESSARY. TO ADDRESS THIS
EPIDEMIC. THE GOOD NEWS IS WE
DON'T NEED TO REINVENT THE WHEEL
HERE WE'VE HEARD LOTS OF
EXAMPLES OF WHAT TRIBES ARE
DOING IT OTHER STATES ARE DOING.
TO ADDRESS THIS EPIDEMIC VARIOUS
INITIATIVES PROGRAMS FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES. AND WHILE THESE
EFFORTS ARE WIDELY VARIED. THEY
SHARE A COMMON. THEME EDUCATION
COMPASSION COOPERATION. AND
PARTNERSHIP. ASSEMBLY TRIBAL
LEADERS WE QUITE LITERALLY
WORKING TOGETHER HAVE THE POWER
TO SAVE LIVES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT POWERFUL-
TESTIMONY THERE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OF THE
CHAMBER REGINALD OUT OF MAKE
THIS QUICK BECAUSE- ONE OF THE
THINGS I MIGHT BE ABLE TO HELP
WITH- IMMEDIATELY WHEN YOU
TALKED ABOUT- IF YOU WOULD HAVE
TRAVELS SOVEREIGNTY BUT PEACE
OFFICERS AND POSSIBLY HAVEN'T
PEACE OFFICER STATUS- I'VE BEEN
VERY SUCCESSFUL. AT GETTING
PEACE OFFICER STATUS WORKERS
CALL THE EXPOSITION POLICE BASE
AROUND. THE COLISEUM IN
EXPOSITION PARK I'VE ALSO GOTTEN
POLICE OFFICER SATISH FOR
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICERS- AND SOMETIMES S. C.
BELIEVE THEIR SOVEREIGNTY UNTO
THEMSELVES BUT THEY'VE GOTTEN.
FULL PLEASE STATUS SO IT CAN BE
DONE I JUST NEED TO KNOW WHAT
HAS BEEN THE STUMBLING BLOCK
AND- ALL OF THAT COMES TO MY
COMMITTEE PUBLIC SAFETY SO AS
WE- AS WE MOVE FORWARD- I DON'T
KNOW IF. IF I DO IT WILL DO IT
MISTER RAMOS BECAUSE EVERYTHING
IS A FIGHT OVER HERE WHO WANTS
TO. DO THESE BILLS BUT- SWEPT IT
TO EVER BRINGS IT. AND WHOEVER
BRINGS IT- LET'S START EARLY
ABOUT IT BUT THE THING I WANT TO
DO MORE THAN ANYTHING ELSE AS I
WAS TELLING YOU WE'RE DOING THIS
PIECEMEAL WITH DIFFERENT POLICE
ENTITIES. IF WE CAN DO ONE
GLOBAL TRAVELS STATEWIDE.
AUTHORIZATION FOR POLICE
OFFICERS THAT IS FOR EVERY
TRIBAL- PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICER-
WOULD BE PROBABLY THE BEST WAY
TO DO IT OTHERWISE I DON'T COME
IN FOR YOUR TRIBE AND ANOTHER
ONE AND THEN ANOTHER ONE. IT IS
SO FRUSTRATING. SOMETIMES LET'S.
LET'S COME UP WITHOUT A PLAN AND
THEN BUT MOST IMPORTANT. TO KEEP
YOUR PUBLIC LAW TO RADIO
RIPARIAN NEED TO HAVE A JUST A
HEARING ON THAT BECAUSE I'VE
HEARD. IT BE PROBLEMATIC ON
SEVERAL. SEVERAL CASES. THANK
YOU A MISTER CHAIRMAN THE%
PUBLIC. SAFETY COMMITTEE FOR THE
ASSEMBLY AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OFFER TO HELP- REMEDY SOME OF
THE SOLUTIONS ARE ARE COMING
FORWARD AND HOPEFULLY- THE
CHAIRS ARE TAKING DIALOGUE AND
HAVING YOUR YOUR PEOPLE ALREADY
CALLED HIS OFFICE TO SET UP A
MEETING TO FURTHER THE
DISCUSSION- IT IT'S NOT A
FIGHTER WHO'S GONNA MOVE FORWARD
AS WE MOVE FORWARD FOR THE FIRST
PEOPLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- FOR THE ISSUES THAT
ARE ARE DRASTICALLY AFFECTING
ONE PERSON CAN'T DO IT ALL SO
IT'S GOOD TO HAVE COLLEAGUES IN
THE SUPPORT HERE. THAT YOU'RE
HEARING- FROM THE DYESS- NOT
SURE OF- CRITICISM AGUIAR-CURRY-
I'M SORRY CAME IN LATE THIS BEEN
A BUSY DAY BUT I'M REALLY HAPPY
AS YOUR FOR THE POINT THAT I DID
HEAR. WHAT I HEAR LET'S KEEP OUR
DIALOGUE GOING GUARANTEED IT'S
NOT TOO DIFFICULT TO DO THAT WE
JUST HAVE TO SET THE TIME I
REALLY LIKE AN IDEA OF A BLUE
RIBBON COMMITTEE I'VE DONE THAT
ON SOME PROJECTS AND SO MY
COUNTIES AND THEY WORK REALLY
WELL IT'S ALWAYS A LITTLE BIT
HARD IN THE NATIONAL TO GET
EVERYBODY TO SIT DOWN AT A TABLE
AND HAVE THOSE DISCUSSIONS BUT
THEY DO WORK IN THE SUCCESSFUL.
WOULD WANT AN OUTCOME OF THAT
FIGHT WITH WHAT KIND OF THINGS
TO COME OUT OF THAT- I'M- THE
WHAT WE'RE- WHY. I THINK YOU
WERE JUST SAYING ABOUT THE KNOW
HOW WE PUT THIS ALL. AND NUMBER
ONE WHATEVER PUT TOGETHER HERE I
WANNA MAKE SURE WE CAN
IMPLEMENT. YOU KNOW WHAT'S THE
PROBLEM HOW DO YOU FIX IT AND SO
MANY TIMES WE HAVE LEGISLATION
THIS BUILDING. AS ALL OF US KNOW
THE DOESN'T GET IMPLEMENTED. SO
AS WE SIT DOWN AND YOU SIT DOWN
WITH ALL OF US WHATEVER LET'S DO
REAL STRONG FRAMEWORK. AND EACH
YEAR FOR NEED TO COME BACK AND
BUILD ON IT BUILD ON IT BUILD ON
IT THAT ONLY MAKES REALLY REALLY
STRONG POLICY. AND I'M YOU KNOW
I'M COMMITTED TO HELP OUT OF.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ON THIS ON THIS-
IT TAKES SOME TIME AND I KNOW
ONE OF THE THINGS REALLY
FRUSTRATING. I LOVE LUCY PAUL.
NEED TO HAPPEN IMMEDIATELY. YEAH
WE WOULD LIKE TO LAS.
IMMEDIATELY BUT IS THIS IS A
START RIGHT. AND SO- THIS IS NOT
THE END OF THE CONVERSATION SO
THANK YOU FOR ALL OF YOU THAT
WERE HERE I'M SORRY I MISSED
SOME INTERESTING MONEY BUT- I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU. CAME TODAY.
OF THIS NEEDS TO BE ELEVATED
THIS INFORMATION IS TO BE
ELEVATED- MORE MORE MY FRIENDS
OF SAID I DIDN'T REALIZE THIS IS
GOING ON IN OUR COMMUNITIES. AND
SO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
MAKING. SURE BRINGS IT TO OUR
PUBLIC SEARS. THANK YOU- SO
MEMBER. AND IN THIS OF MISSING-
INDIAN PERSONS FROM. IN
RESERVATIONS TRAVEL COMMUNITIES
ISN'T SOMETHING NEW IT'S BEEN
HAPPENING I KNOW SINCE WE'VE
BEEN GROWING UP WHAT'S WHAT'S
NEW IS THAT THERE'S THE ADVOCACY
HAS NOW- GARNERED ATTENTION THAT
NOW IS BRINGING THESE ISSUES TO
LIGHT- THERE HAS BEEN. A LOT-
WITHIN INDIAN COUNTRY FOR YEARS
GOING ON SO IT'S NOT JUST A
NUMBER A NEW CRISIS IT'S BEEN A
CRISIS AND THIS IS JUST ONE OF
THE CRISIS HAS AFFECTED- INDIAN
PEOPLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOSTER CARE- IS A BIG
ONE ALSO IN THE KIDS GOING
MISSING BUT NO ONE'S BEEN
NOTIFIED. OF THOSE ISSUES- AND
RESERVATIONS FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S CLOSE TO THE
BORDER- WE HEAR A LOT OF THE
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT ARE GOING
ON WITH BORDER- AREAS BORDER
CITIES AMPLIFY THAT WITH THE
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS I MEAN WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT THE MENTAL HEALTH
COMPONENTS- TWENTY TIMES HIGHER
THAN OTHER AREAS ALL THESE
ISSUES THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
OUT SEE THE AVERAGE. IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH ALL
ETHNICITIES WE'VE HEARD SOME
SHORT TERM SOLUTIONS AN ALERT
SYSTEM KEPT HAVING A OCCURRING-
THEME AND PUSH FOR THAT BUT WE
ALSO HEARD THAT- THE- CLIPS AND
SOMEONE USE THAT THE TERM TAPS
AS FAR AS ANOTHER A REPORTING
LAW ENFORCEMENT TYPE DEAL
THERE'S ACCESS TO THOSE TYPES OF
THINGS AND WILL FURTHER THE
DISCUSSION. ON THAT BUT ALSO THE
UNDERSTANDING OF PUBLIC LAW TO
EIGHTY WITH THE JURISDICTIONS
THAT- LOCAL COUNTY SHARE OF
SENATE NOW IN SOME CASES CITIES
THAT BORDER- FEDERAL INDIAN
RESERVATIONS NEED TO HAVE A TRUE
UNDERSTANDING OF THAT- MOVE YOU
FORWARD AND YOU GOT TENSION OF
THE CHAIR. OF PUBLIC SAFETY ON
THE- POLICING A THOUGHT OUT FOR
TRAVEL COMMUNITIES THAT WANTS TO
BE ABLE TO HEAR MORE ABOUT IT
BUT WE ALSO HERE THAT HAS TO BE
FOR THE STATE RIGHT SO THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO DO SOME
WORK TO THAT BUT THAT'S STUFF
THAT THAT WE WANT TO. BRING FOR.
THAT THE ADVOCACY IN THE
PLATFORM- THAT WERE ABLE TO DO
THROUGH THIS- I HEARING AND-
CAUCUS THAT WE CHAIR IN THE
SELECT COMMITTEE SO THAT WE
BRING THESE ISSUES TO THE
FOREFRONT. WE'VE ALSO HEARD
ABOUT PREVENTION- PREVENTION AS
FAR AS SOCIAL MEDIA WE HEAR THAT
A LOT- WITHIN. OUR DIFFERENT
BILLS AND DIFFERENT TOPICS THAT
WE SEE AND SOMEHOW WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT PREVENTING THE SOCIAL.
MEDIA DOES IT GO OUT FOR-
TRAFFICKING BOASTING SOMEHOW
WHEN IT COMES TO THAT THE TRIBAL
COMMUNITY SOMEHOW THE RESOURCES
DON'T REACH THOSE COMMUNITIES TO
ENSURE. THAT THE OPPORTUNITIES
THERE ALSO TO BE AWARE OF THE
SITUATIONS THAT ARE THERE SO I
THINK JUST AS HAPPENED WITH THE
BROADBAND. DEBTS THAT ONE SENSE
INCLUDING TRIBAL COMMUNITIES
MAYBE WE NEED TO BE LOOKING AT
BILLS THAT COME OUR WAY. THAT
WOULD INCLUDE- TRAVEL
COMMUNITIES FOR RESOURCES-
MOVING FORWARD. THE BLUE RIBBON-
COMMISSION IS A GREAT- A GREAT A
SOLUTION- A NICE VIEW THAT AS
SOMETHING LONG TERM RIGHT THAT
WE COULD PUT TOGETHER. AND THAT
CONTINUES TO BE ADHERED TO AND
AN AMENDED ALONG THE WAY. SO I
THINK WE'VE HEARD SOME- SHORT
TERM SOLUTIONS SOLUTIONS TO WORK
ON- BUT ALSO A STRATEGY. MOVING
FORWARD SO I WANT TO- THANK YOU
THANK YOU ALL FOR THE PANEL
DISCUSSION I KNOW WE HAD A PRESS
CONFERENCE THIS MORNING WE
BROUGHT UP SOME SERIOUS ISSUES
THAT ARE. IN EAL TIME WHERE.
THE VICE CHAIR OF ROUND VALLEY
INDIAN TRIBE SPOKE TO AN ISSUE
OF ONE OF THEIR MEMBERS RIGHT
MEMBERS IT WAS A- VIOLATED AND
LEFT. THEREAFTER BOB WEIR AND
THAT'S HAPPENING TODAY. THAT
GOES TO THE SONGS THAT THEY THAT
ARE BEING SONG. IT'S PEOPLE.
THIS CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE.
AND WE ALL HAVE TO COME TOGETHER
TO. WORK ON THESE ISSUES
TOGETHER- THESE ARE REAL ISSUES
THAT AFFECT OUR PEOPLE. TONIGHT
WILL CONTINUE- WITH- THE MMI PAY
MISSING AND MURDERED INDIGENOUS
PERSONS WE HAVE A PLAY- AT. AT
SIX PM. OVER AT THE MUSEUM
AUDITORIUM. WHERE THE FIRST
PARTNERS GOING TO KICK IT OFF
AND THAT'S AN ALL INDIAN CAST-
DONE BY- IS ABOUT MAGIC OUT-
WHOSE CAREER. IS THE DAUGHTER OF
MY GOOD FRIEND- LOOP MADRUGADA
WHO'S PASSED ON. SO ALL THIS HIS
HOME. WE THAT PLAY IS MONERO AND
HER SISTERS MANY THE MOON THE
SISTERS OF THE STARS AND THEY'RE
GOING TO BRING THAT TOGETHER AND
IT'S A PLAY ABOUT. MISSING AND
MURDERED INDIGENOUS WOMEN NINE
INVITE ALL THOSE TO ATTEND IT'S
AT SIX PM AT THE MUSEUM
AUDITORIUM- WITH THAT- LAW FOR
ANY CLOSING REMARKS FROM THE
PANEL. I'D LIKE TO SAY SOMETHING
. SO THIS MORNING AND I FORGIVE
ME I FORGET WHO SAID THIS BUT
THAT TRIBAL LEADERS AND YOURSELF
HAVE DONE AN ABSOLUTELY AMAZING
JOB IN BRINGING THIS ISSUE TO
THE FOREFRONT AND NOW THAT IT'S-
IN THE TOP OF EVERYBODY'S MIND
THE NEXT STEP IS TO IMPLEMENT
ACTION. AND SO WE'RE READY TO DO
THAT WE WILL STAND WITH YOU AND
THERE'S A SAYING I ALWAYS JACK
IT UP BUT I'M GONNA TRY TO SEE
IT RIGHT NOW. WE GO. FARTHER WE
FARTHER TOGETHER I DID IT DAMAGE. SO WE'RE HERE TO WORK WITH YOU
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT. IN REPUBLICAN. COULD DO
THE MICROPHONE OR FROM WHEREVER
YOU CAN HAVE MY CHANCE. FOR GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LOUIS WILL
PULL IN THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE RUN VALLEY INDIAN TRIBES IN.
NORTHERN MENDOCINO COUNTY. SOME
NO TEACHER ROSE WRITTEN BY
MISSING ON FEBRUARY EIGHTH TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN HAS BEEN FOR
OVER FOUR YEARS WE HAVE NO CLUE-
WE REACH FOR HELP WE ASK FOR
HELP YOU KNOW THERE'SNO
RESOURCES AVAILABLE FOR INDIAN
COUNTRIES- NO WHAT CAN WE DO-
SELECT A SURE WOMEN DO SHE SAYS
IT WILL HAVE TO IMPROVE REINVENT
THE WHEEL THAT'S ALREADY MADE.
YOU KNOW THERE'S LIKE THERE'S
THE AMBER ALERT HOW CAN WE DO WE
KNOW WE ASK FOR HOOKHAM OUR
PEOPLE CAN HAVE A LAWYER YOU
KNOW THERE'S CERTAIN THINGS OUT
THERE THAT'S ALREADY THERE THAT
OUR PEOPLE CAN HAVE YOU KNOW IN
ROUTE I'M VERY THANKFUL FOR YOU
MISTER ASSEMBLY RAMIS THERE
BECAUSE YOU'VE GOT A LOT THIS TO
LIGHT YOU KNOW IT'S MOVING
FORWARD THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS
OUT THERE THAT'S GOING TO MOVE
FORWARD FOR OUR PEOPLE ALL
PEOPLE ARE INDIAN PEOPLE. YOU
KNOW IT'S AWESOME BUT THERE'S
YOU KNOW THERE'S RESOURCES OUT
THERE THAT ARE THERE THAT'S NOT
MADE READILY AVAILABLE FOR OUR
INDIAN PEOPLE YOU KNOW WE ASK
WHY WHY IS IT THAT AVAILABLE FOR
US WHY ISN'T THERE NO FUNDING
FOR AS WHY CAN'T WE OUR VOICES
BE HEARD AND LOOKED AT IT
SERIOUSLY YOU KNOW WHAT CAN WE
DO A SERIES ONE I MEAN SO.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
IT'S AWESOME. BECAUSE THIS IS
EXACTLY WHY WE HAVE THESE
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS. IS TO
EDUCATE THOSE OF US THAT ARE NOT
AWARE. AND THIS IS REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT IN YOU MADE THE
THERE'S NOT MANY. BUT OR WHAT IT
IN THERE ARE. BECAUSE WE RUN
AROUND BUT- I JUST WANNA SURE
YOU THAT THAT'S MORTGAGE. FOR US
THE BETTER OFF I'VE HAD. I HAD
TO TEACH PEOPLE ABOUT. THE LIVE
IN THE OF L. IT'S- EDUCATED.
THEM IT'S WORKS AND SO- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ROB AS BROAD IT TO THE
FLOOR. AND WE ARE ALL.
APPRECIATIVE OF WE'VE HAD. A LOT
OF LEARNING WE'VE DONE THE PAST
COUPLE OF YEARS AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO DO SO BUT- IT REALLY
IS ABOUT EDUCATION. I KEEP
TALKING TO YOUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
YOUR SENATORS. YEAH TELL ME
IMPORTANCE BECAUSE IF HEY DON'T
HEAR FROM YOU. YOU KNOW IT MAY
GO UNDER THE CARPET AGAIN BUT
LET'S BUT WE GOT LEADERS I
THINK- AND- HAVING- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SORRY. ALL GOOD. AND
OTHER WOMEN'S CAUCUS- THERE'S
USUALLY THIRTY TWO OF US AND
IT'S BEEN CRAZY WE HAVE A COUPLE
THANK RIGHT NOW BUT- I ASSURE
YOU THAT WE'RE WE'RE HEARD YOU.
WE HEARD YOU. WITH THIS AT HOME
AND RATHER INDIAN TRIBES IF YOU
YOU'RE NOT THE RIGHT FROM YOUR
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT REACH OUT
TO US AND WILL WORK TO
COORDINATE A MEETING TO ENSURE
THAT YOU'RE AT THE TABLE- AND
THERE AT THE TABLE- SO WE COULD
GET INVOLVED IN THAT ASPECT OF
IT. AND IF THAT'S NOT HAPPENING
PLEASE CONTACT OUR OFFICE AT
FROM WE SURE WILL. AND ALSO- THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL- WHO WAS AT THE
PRESS CONFERENCE. COULD ACTUALLY
TIE HIM INTO IT TOO- THROUGH HIS
ASSISTANT. MERRY LOPEZ KEEPER
WHOSE POINT IN THE SAME. BUT I
ALSO WANT TO RECOGNIZE- THE
TRIBAL COUNCIL MEMBERS THAT ARE
HERE- CALIFORNIA INDIAN TRIBAL
LEADERS THERE HERE AND
ESPECIALLY THE YOUTH- TRIBAL
YOUTH THAT ARE HERE. IN THIS
CHAMBER. INTO ALL THOSE THAT ARE
THERE. WE NEED MORE CALIFORNIA
INDIAN PEOPLE ALIKE DIDN'T TO
THE STATE LEGISLATURE TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES AND TO WORK WITH
COLLEAGUES TO EDUCATE HIM ON THE
ISSUES THAT ARE IMPORTANT TO OUR
PEOPLE SO TO THE YOUTH AND TO
ALL THOSE THAT ARE OUT THERE-
AND I DID MAKE A STATEMENT I
CAN'T DO ALL THESE BILLS ON A
WRONG. EDUARDO GARCIA IS A GOOD
FRIEND OF MINE- REGGIE JONES
SAWYER AND- ASSEMBLY- WOMAN
AGUIAR-CURRY WE WERE ON ALL
THESE ISSUES TO- FAR MORE. WELL
WE DO NEED- MORE. IN PEOPLE
ELECTED TO THE STATE LET- DOES
THAT ARE SPEAK. AND GIVING TED.
ALL LIKE. COULD THINK ABOUT WAS
YOU COULD BE SENT IN ONE OF
THESE SEATS RIGHT. AT THE SAME
TIME INTO THE YOUTH THAT'S OUT
THERE- YOU'VE HEARD THE
TESTIMONY TODAY. YOU'VE SEEN THE
PRESS CONFERENCE WE'RE GONNA BE
GOING TO THAT PLAY- HERE LATER
ON THIS EVENING. BUT THERE'S NO
REASON YOU CAN'T BE IN THE SEATS
THERE'S NO REASON THAT YOU CAN
INSPIRE. TO BE A LEADER IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BY YOU BEING
HERE YOU'RE ALREADY LEADING THE
YOUTH. OF CALIFORNIA PEOPLE SO I
JUST WANT TO PLEDGE YOU FOR
THAT. YOU COULD APPLY. WITH THE.